welcome to the huberman Lab podcast
where we discuss science and
science-based tools for everyday
[Music]
life I'm Andrew huberman and I'm a
professor of neurobiology and
Opthalmology at Stanford School of
Medicine my guest today is Dr Natalie
Crawford Dr Natalie Crawford is a
medical doctor specializing in
Obstetrics and Gynecology reproductive
endocrinology and infertility she also
holds a degree in nutrition science Dr
Crawford runs a clinical practice seen
patients daily as well as being actively
involved in public education both
through social media and through her
popular podcast entitled as a woman
today Dr Crawford teaches us about all
aspects of female hormones and Hormone
Health and fertility beginning as far
back as in utero when we were still in
our mother's womb and extending as far
forward as menopause we discussed topics
such as the timing of puberty and what
the timing of puberty in girls means for
their fertility and we discussed birth
control both hormonal and non- hormonal
forms of birth control and how birth
control may or may not relate to
long-term fertility and different
aspects of female Health we also talk
extensively about measuring fertility
that is egg count we also talk about egg
retrieval AKA freezing one's eggs as
well as invitro fertilization and we
also take a deep dive into the popular
and important topics of nutrition and
supplementation as they relate to
fertility as they relate to pregnancy
but also how they relate to female
hormone Health generally indeed Dr
Crawford provides us with a master class
on female hormones and fertility one
that I know that all women ought to
benefit from and that men would benefit
from listening to as well before we
begin I'd like to emphasize that this
podcast is separate from my teaching and
research roles at Stanford it is however
part of my desire and effort to bring
zero cost to Consumer information about
science and science related tools to the
general public in keeping with that
theme I'd like to thank the sponsors of
today's podcast our first sponsor is
Maui Nei venison Maui venison is the
most nutrient-dense and delicious red
meat available I've spoken before on
this podcast in Solo episodes and with
guests about the need to get
approximately one gram of highquality
protein per pound of body weight each
day for optimal nutrition now there are
many different ways that one can do that
but a key thing is to make sure that
you're not doing that by ingesting
excessive calories Maui Nei venison has
the highest density of quality protein
per calorie and it achieves that in
delicious things like ground Meats
venison steaks jerky and bone broth I
particularly like the ground venison I
make those into venison burgers probably
five times a week or more I also like
the jerky for its convenience especially
when I'm traveling or I'm especially
busy with work and know that I'm getting
an extremely nutrient-dense highquality
source of protein if you'd like to try
Maui Nei venison you can go to Maui Nei
Venison
docomo and get 20% off your first order
again that's Maui venison / huberman to
get 20% off today's episode is also
brought To Us by Helix sleep Helix sleep
makes mattresses and pillows that are
tailored to your unique sleep needs now
sleep is the foundation of mental health
physical health and performance when we
are sleeping well and enough mental
health physical health and performance
all stand to be at their best one of the
key things to getting a great night's
sleep is to make sure that your mattress
is tailor to your unique sleep needs
Helix sleep has a brief two-minute quiz
that if you go to their website you take
that quiz and answer questions such as
do you tend to sleep on your back your
side or your stomach do you tend to run
hot or cold in the middle of the night
maybe you don't know the answers to
those questions and that's fine at the
end of that two-minute quiz they will
match you to a mattress that's ideal for
your sleep needs I sleep on the dusk D
us mattress and when I started sleeping
on a dusk mattress about 2 years ago my
sleep immediately improved so if you're
interested in upgrading your mattress go
to helixsleep.com
huberman take their two-minute sleep
quiz and they'll match you to a
customized mattress for you and you'll
get up to $350 off any mattress order
and two free pillows again if interested
go to helixsleep.com huberman for up to
$350 off and two free pillows I'm
pleased to announce that we will be
hosting four live events in Australia
Each of which is entitled The Brain body
contract during which I will share
science and science related tools for
mental health physical health and
performance there will also be a Live
question and answer session we have
limited tickets still available for the
event in Melbourne on February 10th as
well as the event in Brisbane on
February 24th our event in Sydney at the
Sydney Opera house sold out very quickly
so as a consequence we've now scheduled
a second event in Sydney at the aware
super theater on February 18th to access
tickets to any of these events you can
go to huberman lab.com
events and use the code huberman at
checkout I hope to see you there and as
always thank you for your interest in
science and now for my discussion with
Dr Natalie Crawford Dr Crawford welcome
thank you so much for having me I'm
honored to be here well I've been paying
attention to your content for a long
time and I find it to be incredibly
clear informative and for many people
actionable so today I'd like to talk
about both fertility and of course
hormones but as we both know fertility
is not limited to a discussion about
hormones it actually relates to things
like behaviors yes sex behaviors and
other behaviors nutrition
supplementation so we'll get into all of
it but if we could just back up
developmentally and talk a little bit
about female puberty because I think
pretty much everything we'll talk about
today is related to what happens puberty
forward mostly in females but we will
also discuss male fertility and hormones
a bit and the question I have is is
there anything about a woman's timing
or let's just say patterns of puberty
right how frequent
they menstrate early on what the timing
of menstration is uh in terms of their
age Etc that provides hints or maybe
even facts or directives about her
future fertility or how long her
fertility might last this is a great
question and I think defining some
terminology before we begin is helpful
so if we go all the way back to when
you're a fetus inside your mom so when
there's a female fetus inside your mom
you have the most eggs you're ever going
to have at about 20 weeks gestation you
have about 6 to 7 million eggs by the
time you're born you've already lost
more than half of those and you
continually lose eggs all the time so
the analogy that I always use and you do
too is imagining that there's a vault
inside the ovary where all your eggs are
kept and every single month since the
moment you have an ovary you lose a
group of these eggs and when there's
more inside you're losing more so you're
losing all of these eggs throughout
early fetal development and then up
until the time period even of puberty
when you reach puberty you have a
lessening of the number of eggs in your
ovary to the point where it can start to
respond to the signals from the brain so
we think about puberty aret in females
first we have really thearchy which is
the development of breasts so that
happens about two years on average
before you have minarchy which is your
period starting so what happens is the
brain as we know from the hypothalamus
sends out G&R and then we have FSH
coming out which really starts to
stimulate those follicles so fshr
follicle stimulating hormone well-named
hormone for the female of course men
have it too and it's less well- named
for them but it starts to get those
follicles which house the eggs to grow
and make estrogen women have about 2
years of estrogen exposure alone so
unopposed estrogen with no progesterone
because they're not yet ovulating and
that's when you start to see breast
budding and you start to see the
development of some of those secondary
sex characteristics before you actually
have a period what are some of the other
secondary sex characteristics that
precede menarchy um so you said uh
breast Bud development and then breast
development on average about two years
before before you have sexual hair
development so actually adrin Archy is
one of the first usually comes right
before at the same time with breast buds
so two to three years before you'll see
your period And so genital hair underarm
hair yeah genital hair usually first and
then underarm hair um and we're getting
right down into the weeds here which is
good um you know a goal of this podcast
is to normalize all aspects of Health
including sexual health and and
reproductive Health um is that
commensurate also with um the
development of body odor yes you know
because as a young boy who eventually
hit puberty and became a young man and
now I suppose I'm in middle age um 48 um
I can tell you that the the locker room
smelled a lot different um be before
before and after Middle School right
right like the in other words boys start
to smell stinky um right they do yes and
that's usually around that same time of
sexual hair development is when you
start to have those glands around the
hair making some of those odors that
start to produce stink do they reflect
hormones themselves not this like the
smell the actual smell doesn't actually
reflect levels of hormones or anything
like that it is just that your body your
gonads whether it is testes or ovaries
are now starting to respond to those
brain signals the brain is turned on
they're starting to respond and your
body is starting to mature in a way to
get to the point where it can support
reproduction the reason I asked that
question is not to get people thinking
about um stinky smells but um and by the
way some people love the musty smell of
of their own uh armpits or others you
know we're referring to adults um by the
way um but the reason I ask is that
there's a wealth of data in animal
models including cluding non-human
primates suggesting that um exposure to
the odors of others can either um
stimulate or accelerate puberty um is
there any evidence for that in humans so
there's mild evidence and it's murky
because we also know that anything that
could be an endocrine disruptor which a
lot of scents or fragrances are also can
accelerate the onset of puberty by
disrupting part of this system and so we
know that toxins and you know scents and
a lot of the world that we're exposed to
is part of the reason why we're seeing
puberty happening at such a younger age
now in females specifically but in both
but in females than we have before we
have young girls seeing their onset of
menarchy or their period at a much
younger age how much younger I I've seen
the various graphs for different
countries but can we say that you know
10 years ago on average um girls in the
United States and Northern Europe were
hitting menarchy at about what 12 to 13
years of age yeah so you know start
we'll use menarchy for the purpose of
this so having your period you know 10
to 20 years ago you will see most data
would say oh 13 to 15 would have been
kind of the average age and now we're
really seeing it shift to be starting at
10 to 11 and completing by 1314 so most
girls are definitely going through the
puberty change earlier and the other
thing to note is that most girls get
their final height growth right before
they start their period too so not only
are we seeing a change in this getting
starting earlier what we're also seeing
is probably some reduction in height
from having gone through puberty at an
earlier process because once you start
actually menstrating once the ovaries
have really started to learn how to
respond to that FSH and grow the
follicle and it gets to the point where
you can start ovulating so about 2 years
later then that ovulatory period those
high levels of estrogen are going to go
and they're going to close those growth
plates so you've really started to limit
your final adult height as well when you
go through puberty earlier and that's
definitely something that's a huge
concern for precocious puberty or very
young puberty right and we can use
blockers when there are children who
start to exhibit signs of puberty and
one of the main reasons people do that
is to try to get them to a greater adult
height if they're really starting to go
through puberty at a very young age is
that also true for males that it's
happening earlier that earlier puberty
means that your growth spurt uh in terms
of height is going to be uh truncated
not the same and you probably most men
will say oh but I had my growth spur you
know kind of after I started having some
of the puberty change that happened but
because it is this estrogen related
process and women that we see that gross
bird really your final height is within
that year of when your period starts
interesting yeah this uh discussion is
certainly not about me but I was one of
these what I thought was kind of an odd
duck I hit puberty about 13
14 um let's just say I knew I did um but
I didn't shave until I was after college
my growth spurt between freshman and
sophomore year I grew a foot right so I
was like you know grew a full foot but I
was the same weight so I was like real
tall real skinny or pretty- tall you
know real skinny and then it seems like
um you know some people in my life would
argue that puberty is still occurring
for me but it feels like it's very long
and protracted which leads me to a a a
um a very specific question um if
puberty arrives let's again defined as
menarchy um for sake of our discussion
right now if puberty arrives early in a
girl does that mean that her fertility
will shut down earlier as well great
question it does not so the age of which
you start the onset of your period does
not impact how long you're going to have
a reproductive lifespan and that's
because you have the eggs inside that
Vault you're losing them every month
month no matter what so you lost them
all those years before your period
started no matter if your period came at
10 or at 15 it's just about when did
they start allowing your body to ovulate
determined by being able to carry a baby
your body now thinks you can be pregnant
I think this is so important to
highlight because it puts together what
you said earlier about the loss of eggs
even in um as a fetus um I think most
people sort of assume that the reduction
in egg count is due to ovulation and the
fact that you know one egg ovulates
typically but that other eggs are
deployed in that ovulatory cycle and
then those those basically are taken out
of the Vault and out of the opportunity
for fertilization but what you're saying
is that the eggs are constantly being C
From the Vault starting from early
embryonic development and that ovulation
is a distinct step in some sense
unrelated to to to the loss of eggs I
think this is going to be be very
important for our discussion later about
potential egg Harvest yes because I
think some people have it in mind a lot
of misconceptions that you're losing
eggs from your fault and that's not the
case you're just accessing the ones
outside gosh so you're not um so we can
just answer this now perhaps it seems if
I understand correctly that if one were
to harvest eggs for IVF or for
embryogenesis in a dish to set them
aside later or freeze them for later um
if they want to use them eggs or or
fertilized embryos that one is
not reducing the total number of eggs
any more than they would had they just
let their their Cycles proceed naturally
exactly oh that's such an important
point I think that I think a lot of
people believe the opposite they it's
probably the number one thing that
patients fear when they come talk to me
about egg freezing or going through IVF
is I don't want to harm my future
fertility I don't want to cause myself
to run out of eggs earlier or going into
menopause earlier and it's explaining
this process to them that your ovaries
are on a pathway that you can't change
those eggs are coming out of the Vault
regardless of if you're on birth control
pills you're pregnant we do IVF what
we're modifying is one's not going to
ovulate and have the rest of them die
we're going to try to give you
medication to get them all to grow so we
can take all of the ones that have been
released from the Vault that month and
give them a chance for later and the
next month you'll have another group
come out so IVF is not about stimulating
hyper relase or excessive release of
eggs it's about stimulating the growth
of the ones that have been released so
that they can be Frozen at stage either
for later fertilization or fertilized in
addition than Frozen as embryos is that
right exactly and we just use the
hormones that your body normally makes
in a different way the medications we
use are FSH and LH to get the eggs to
grow so people will say I don't want to
take all these weird hormones or strange
medications but we're just manipulating
that normal process that happens in the
natural menstrual cycle in order to say
hey this month let's get all these eggs
to grow let's try to improve the
efficiency
of finding which eggs are going to be
normal or not and help you along this
process I think a good number of people
are now going to uh head to the IVF
Clinic I think again I really want to
highlight this I I think most people
that I've spoken to assume that the
process of harvesting eggs for
freezing for fertilization then or later
is going to diminish their fertility
because they're basically pulling more
out of the savings account so to speak
right okay so you're making the
withdrawal no matter what great well um
such an important point for for people
to know and and propagate um getting
back to puberty uh a little bit later on
I wanted to get into endocrine
disruptors and things of that sort but
since you brought it up um you know I've
heard things such as okay things like
evening primrose oil if Mom is putting
evening primrose oil on or has it in her
shampoo that I've heard of young males
getting um precocious breast Bud
development and keep in mind folks that
some transient breast Bud development is
um characteristic of some normal
puberties in males it sometimes shows up
and goes I knew some kids like that in
the neighborhood they got teased a
little bit and then they stopped getting
teased hopefully nowadays they don't
tease those kids but when I was growing
up those kids got teased not by me but
by other people but it was normal in it
pasted for for some right it occurred um
normally and then ped but I've heard
that things like exposure to evening
primrose oil maybe even just through
contact with Mom can um increase the the
frequency or degree of that male breast
Bud development is it also true
that young girls can undergo precocious
puberty or let's just say accelerated or
exacerbated puberty um through contact
with things like evening primrose oil
which is a I think has some pseudo
estrogen like properties it's important
to differentiate that the secondary sex
characteristics we see like breast Bud
development are from estrogen but it's
not really puberty being initiated when
it's from an endocrine disrupting
chemical so taking you know being
exposed to evening primrose or lavender
or te tea tree oil in a male isn't going
to cause him to start to go into puberty
but it is going to expose him to
estrogen when his body is not and
therefore stimulate some breast bed
development same thing can happen in
young girls meaning they could show some
of those secondary sex signs earlier
than they normally would and this is why
if that's happening at a really young
age kids should go to a pediatric
endocrinologist who are going to check
things like bone age and see if you've
really started the puberty process or
not or is it an outside exposure which
is causing it interestingly about the
young child exposure and development the
other thing to say that's really
interesting and relevant in my field is
that when we think about how many eggs
are in the vault and everybody's born
with this different number and I'm sure
we'll talk about ovarian reserve what we
now know is that the Vault your ovaries
are most susceptible to whatever your
mother does when she's pregnant with you
and that that epigenetic that
programming which is happening is
predisposing young women to probably
having some of them low ovarian reserve
some of them having diseases we
associate with infertility like PCOS or
endometriosis and we haven't yet
characterized what all they are but if
we look at the incidence of some of
these disease that we see now what we do
know is that the time period of which
these people were pregnant the 80s and
90s was not the healthiest time when it
comes to endocrine disruptors and
plastic exposures and chemicals and all
of this processed stuff let's just say
that people have been exposed to that
we're really seeing that those that
ovarian susceptibility to egg quality
and quantity happens in that fetal
development period it's interesting uh
because there are some uh parallels to
male fetal development like the the fact
that you have these or early organizing
effects of hormones like
dihydrotestosterone which essentially
stimulate the growth of the penis but
also then establish a a propensity for
hormones during puberty to activate
growth of the sex organs but also
activate the brain areas they're
responsible for a host of different
things so I only mention that because uh
what I'd like to kind of illustrate in
the background here is that um basically
our reproductive Health
begins really prior prior to conception
really it's a dependent on Mom and Dad
but um certainly to a great degree on on
mom um but then fetal development is
going to be important so sort of um us
uh being able to pick our parents um I I
do have a couple questions about
lavender tea tree oil and evening
primrose oil I was aware that evening
Prim oil oil excuse me can um somehow
bind estrogen receptors or mimic uh some
of the estr or something similar to it I
wasn't aware of tea tree oil or lavender
um here are we talking about oils what
about Aromas and how concerned do people
have to be about this stuff because I
mean you know you'll go into a
restaurant bathroom there'll be popere
uh some people wear perfume I mean we
don't want to set a paranoia but but I
but I think people should know about
this stuff Teo is in a lot of those um
natural shampoos L burn yes the one that
tingle your scalps some people love them
though constant exposure is very
different than a one-time hand washing
in the bathroom and I think that's a big
difference for everything when we talk
about chemicals or toxins or exposures
in the world you can't live in a
toxin-free world but choosing what you
put in and on your body on a regular
basis does set the tone for certain
physiological changes and so you know
using unscented products especially with
children is really an important thing
because we want to make sure that their
lifetime exposure to some of these
things especially during critical times
is much less and so you'll see people
recommend things like your laundry
detergent you know what sensor in your
laundry detergent the shampoo and
conditioner are a big one and the Soaps
that you use on a day-to-day basis in
your house or the oils you put on your
body Lavender is huge because there's
this whole community of people they want
to rub lavender oil on their baby's feet
and help them sleep but really we can
see and if somebody goes and shadows a
pediatric endocrinologist for a day
they'll see some kids come in and this
will be the reason why uh what about
cloth diapers versus non- cloth diapers
I've heard you know that you have your
like very strong cloth drier proponents
right and that because they seem to um
feel or believe that um non- cloth
diapers somehow contain things that can
get into baby's skin and and maybe
there's a bigger question here is baby
skin more permeable than I gu I don't
know that baby skin is more permeable I
don't either I just to me it seems it
seems like it' be hard to imagine it is
but but babies do seem to have this
incredible skin right their skin is so
smooth and and you want to squeeze their
cheeks and all this kind of stuff but um
yeah had the idea they would be more
permeable I think it's more that their
development is this time is very
important and setting the stage for a
lot of what happens later versus in
adulthood those stepwise developmental
processes have already happened so I
think that's why we pay so much
attention to what happens in the you
know childhood period of time because
we're now learning about those later
consequences of what you're exposed to
it's not that you know regular diapers
versus cloth whatever we want to say it
one's necessarily better than the other
it's more honestly a personal preference
babies are exposed to them a lot and
there's been a lot of attention to that
but similarly somebody could use cloth
and wash it with a detergent that then
you know has certain chemicals in it so
there hasn't been a study shown that
this one thing is an exposure for a baby
that somebody needs to be worried about
there's definitely companies now which
are promoting and talking about you know
traditional diapers that they are making
sure have less toxins in them and I
always think anytime you can decrease
toxin exposure to a child is going to be
very
important is there any evidence for um
you know breast milk versus Formula in
terms of impact on future reproductive
development of or reproductive status of
of a child that's a complicated question
because breast milk exposure at least
for the first 6 months of a child's life
certainly helps with the immune system
development and we know that poor immune
development can lead to higher risk of
autoimmune disease later what people
call leaky gut and some of those
diseases certainly are correlated with
fertility so I wouldn't say we've gone
so far to say that if you don't
breastfeed your child they're going to
have fertility issues but we do know
that there's an in between correlation
with things that breastfeeding is
protective against
and how those diseases themselves May
relate to fertility in the female later
on okay okay so if we're um thinking
about a young girlwoman because we're
talking about puberty right so I don't
know what the exact nomenclature is
there you know my experiences I'll I'll
offend and um somebody no matter what um
but a girl who under goes puberty right
so a young woman um who's maybe 13 or so
so she's early teens um under goes
puberty and therefore is contining to
lose eggs from the Vault um but now is
undergoing uh
presumably roughly every 28 days
manarchy but let's talk about this 28
days thing because I think a lot of
people think that um quote unquote
normal menstration is always 28 days and
and we know that's not true so what is
the the range of uh normal durations
between um menstration uh Cycles or
duration of the menstration cycle and
and let's also Define when the
menstruation cycle starts probably for
the males mostly in the audience sure
sure so let's think through the cycle
we'll do a quick one over and then
answer the questions so what we think of
is cycle day one or when you're going to
say this starts is going to be the day
that you start bleeding so that's
actually shedding the endometrial lining
from what grew the last time so any
spotting even would be considered day
one okay so it is we can get back to it
but there's problematic if you have a
lot of spotting before that full flow
starts a day or so can be really normal
just as the body's adjusting to the drop
in progesterone but let's just start at
the beginning day one you have a period
a menes this is when you're actually
bleeding at this time period we like to
think about all of those new eggs being
out of the Vault being susceptible to
that FSH which of course is that
well-named hormone because it stimulates
a follicle to grow and each egg is in a
follicle that egg starts to grow and
makes estrogen that estrogen stimulates
the proliferation of the lining of the
uterus and preparation for potentially
that pregnancy that may come and also
that estrogen makes you feel really
great right that's the folicular phase
name so because that follicle is growing
and it's an FSH dominant phase where you
have a lot of estrogen and people feel
great when they have a lot of estrogen
because women feel good with estrogen
because of the relationship between
estrogen and other neuromodulators like
dopamine serotonin and and is that
happening in parallel or are they
somehow related like is estrogen
controlling the release of Serotonin
somehow and VI Versa or are they just
kind of coincidentally happening in
parallel we definitely think that
there's more of a correlation causation
than just coincidence because we know
there's time periods of people are more
depressed within your cycle correlating
with those low estrogen levels and we
know that when you go into menopause or
you run out of eggs and you're now in a
low estrogen phase we see a lot more of
a depressed mood and you know anadon
lack of response to things which would
normally give you pleasure happens more
more frequently the female brain loves
estrogen and it's protective against
things like dementia so this is a time
period where women are going to be more
energetic they're going to have more
energy more Focus this is the estrogen
dominant phase of the cycle and when you
have seen that estrogen at its high
levels which it's only made from a
mature follicle and it's very specific
200 pams per milliliter for 50 hours
that's the brain's clue okay we must
have a mature egg and it can send out
that surge of LH or luttin hormone and
now you ovulate and when you ovulate the
follicle opens up releases closes back
and then it's the Corpus ludum and we've
entered the ludal phase and the Corpus
ludum as the name suggests a corpus it's
like a body that's basically the it's
Bas it's basically the the corpse of of
what yeah en sheathed the egg before um
and it what I find so amazing I mean
biology is so beautiful right it instead
of just taking that tissue and saying
okay like let's just discard this or um
that becomes the trigger for the next
phase of the it is essential for life
right the Corpus ludum which makes
progesterone opens and closes the
implantation window it is what allows
somebody to get pregnant and for our
species to continue it's so it's
extremely fascinating and that Corpus
ludum gets stimulated to produce
progesterone imp pulses throughout the
entire ludal phase because it's still
controlled by the brain unless you get
pregnant and then in that ludal phase
progesterone is fast ating it's trying
to protect you from things which could
potentially harm your baby so suddenly
now you have less energy you want to
sleep more you want to eat more you
maybe do not want to have sex as much
because your body is suddenly saying
let's just protect this potential
implantation that you're going to have
if that pregnancy doesn't come the
Corpus ludum can only live 12 to 14 days
it has a very distinct lifespan and then
it dies your estrogen and progesterone
both drop you bleed starting over the
next cycle and a new group of follicles
comes out to be released and the reason
why walking through that very succinctly
but is important when you're asking how
long is the normal cycle because the
ludal phase is pretty set at 12 to 14
days the follicular phase can vary in
person to person and what we know though
is for one individual if your menstrual
cycle your reproductive hormones are
working right it should be Rel
relatively constant for you and so if
your periods are every 24 days but
they've always been every 24 to 25 days
then that's not concerning and if your
periods are every 33 days but they've
always been every 33 days then that's
not concerning but we do get concerned
when there's a change in your period or
we get concerned when people have what I
like to say is irregularly regular
periods because what you'll see
textbooks tell you is that your periods
could be as short as 21 days as long as
35 days and that can all be normal but
people will hop between them and they'll
have one cycle that is 24 days in length
from day one to the last day before the
next day one then the next Cycle's 32
and then it's 26 and then it's 34 and
that's not normal that's too irregular
and that can be a sign that something is
not communicating correctly within your
reproductive hormones so what I tell
patients is in general your period
should be less than 35 days apart and
you should be able to look at a calendar
and with your finger put a finger on the
date and within a couple days of
accuracy be able to predict when your
period's coming and if you can't there
could likely be something that is
interfering with the hormonal signals
between the brain and the ovary and one
of the biggest really one of the only
things we see as women start to have
fewer eggs in the vault is a shortening
of their Cycles so you have a regular
period and suddenly now you have less
eggs in the vault so less are coming out
each month and when the brain sends out
that FSH signal now there's fewer eggs
so it's not getting as dilute and you
have one starting to respond sooner so
suddenly you're ovulating shorter faster
in your cycle you're ovulating on cycle
date 9 instead of 14 your ludal phase is
still set but the person who comes to
see me and says my periods have always
been 28 to 30 days but now they're every
24 I just figure it's no big deal I am
have red flags going off everywhere
because I'm now really concerned that
potentially their ovarian reserve has
dropped to a point where we are starting
to see clinical changes now of course
things like thyroid and prolactin and
other hormones can also cause such
changes but that's why you'll hear most
reproductive endocrinologists say your
period's a Vital sign and what we really
mean is the regularity at which it comes
and the predictability of it is telling
us if your hormones are all
communicating in a normal fashion or if
something could potentially be off as we
all know quality nutrition influences of
course our physical health but also our
mental health and our cognitive
functioning our memory our ability to
learn new things and to focus and we
know that one of the most important
features of highquality nutrition is
making sure that we get enough vitamins
and minerals from highquality
unprocessed or minimally processed
sources as well as enough probiotics and
prebiotics and fiber to support
basically all the cellular functions in
our body including the gut microbiome
now I like most everybody try to get
optimal nutrition from Whole Foods
ideally mostly from minimally processed
or non-processed Foods however one of
the challenges that I and so many other
people face is getting enough servings
of high quality fruits and vegetables
per day as well as fiber and probiotics
that often accompany those fruits and
vegetables that's why way back in 2012
long before I ever had a podcast I
started drinking ag1 and so I'm
delighted that ag1 is sponsoring the
hubman Lab podcast the reason I started
taking ag1 and the reason I still drink
ag1 once or twice a day is that it
provides all of my foundational
nutritional needs that is it provides
insurance that I get the proper amounts
of those vitamins minerals probiotics
and fiber to ensure optimal mental
health physical health and performance
if you'd like to try ag1 you can go to
drink a1.com
huberman to claim a special offer
they're giving away five free travel
packs plus a year supply of vitamin D3
K2 again that's drink a1.com huberman to
claim that special offer let me see if I
have this correct um we've got this
thing that we call the menstrual cycle
the ovulatory
cycle the there's two phases a
follicular phase and a ludal phase here
precedes the ludal phase the ludal phase
tends to be if I heard correctly um
fairly fixed about 14 days mhm um the
follicular phase can vary in duration
maybe 10 to 14 days maybe even 10 to 18
days depending on the person something
about their brain to ovary
communication for those that um aren't
familiar with this um the I always
learned that estrogen primes
progesterone is kind of the really basic
top Contour description of the ovulatory
cycle that you know estrogen is going to
slowly climb toward the the point of
ovulation and then there's a there's a
peak and then a drop and then
progesterone is going to dominate in the
ludal phase the second half you said
that estrogen um is associated with with
a psychological level and a
physiological level more energy um
feelings of Vitality and some of that
estrogen increase is actually coming
from the one egg that got stimulated the
most the the one that got selected right
so picked for the team um potentially
for the team but got picked uh
potentially for fertilization and that
egg sheds its Corpus ludum
which is this piece of the of the egg
that then triggers the progesterone that
dominates the ludal phase do I have that
right mostly mostly yeah please correct
me the follicle in which the egg grows
right when you ovulate it ruptures the
cyst burst a follicle is a cyst a cyst
is a fluid filed structure follicle is a
fluid fill structure that holds an egg
so when you ovulate and you get that LH
surge the cyst bursts it opens up and
the egg comes out of it and then it
reheal and becomes the ludum got it so
just a little bit different in timing
and you're right with estrogen primes
progesterone but really we think about
it the layer of the uterus because
estrogen stimulates the growth of that
lining and then progesterone stabilizes
it and allows implantation to occur but
the sequence of events of when you're
estrogen dominant and progesterone
deficient which is the folicular phase
and people will come in having Labs
drawn randomly and they're all concerned
that they don't have progesterone and
when you talk to them about where they
are in their cycle you say you're not
supposed to have progesterone that's
your follicular phase this is perfectly
normal okay great thanks for that
clarification I get a lot of questions
about birth control but on my social
media handles don't we all don't we all
to be clear
um this it's a vast topic for
exploration but along the lines of what
we're talking about now I've heard and I
suspect it may not be true but tell me
is there any evidence that taking birth
control can disrupt the process that you
just described and when we talk about
birth control we should probably Define
what we're talking about so there are um
hormone-based birth controls aka the
pill there're also hormone-based birth
controls that are not in pill form um
there are iuds that are copper iuds
there are other iuds let's just talk
about hormone-based
contraception in females okay uh if
which many of them as I understand are
estrogen mimics or estrogen themselves
that suppress ovulation do they diminish
or increase the number of eggs that are
taken from the Vault fantastic question
let's talk about what people say is the
pill so let's specifically talk about
combined oral contraception the pill
which has ethanol estrad and some type
of
progestin no contraception does not
change the release of eggs out of the
Vault they are occurring at the same
process and the same pathway you're not
ovulating because that estrogen does
prevent FSH from coming from the brain
so you have the group of eggs still come
out of the Vault there's no FSH they
just all die the next group comes out so
when you are saying are you going to run
out of eggs faster is it going to harm
your fertility does birth control impair
the process the answer is no but there's
a couple important caveats one is that
the birth control pills especially if
you take them continuously or for a
prolonged period of time the the body is
smart and the ovaries start to say we're
not really doing anything and one of
those markers of ovarian reserve we have
is amh and that's antimullerian hormone
and amh is made from the granulosis
cells or the cells that surround every
follicle so in the shortest way possible
more eggs in the vault more come out
every month higher amh fewer eggs in the
vault fewer come out lower amh if your
amh is being suppressed because of the
birth control pill because it's
decreasing the activity of those
granulosis cells you might get a low amh
value when you've been on the birth
control pill for a long time that is
completely reversible but it can be
significant so if somebody is wanting to
get an amh level let's say somebody
comes to my clinic they're not trying to
get pregnant and they're on the pill and
they're considering freezing their eggs
so we're going to check their ovarian
reserve if we draw it I always say this
amh may be up to 30% lower in somebody
who is on the birth control pill so we
can still draw it and if it comes back
in the normal range we feel good but if
it does come back low we're going to
have to make a decision are we going to
stop the birth control pill for a period
of some months use alternative
contraception if you don't want to be
pregnant and then repeat this test to
see if this is a true low because we do
see that young women do have low ovarian
reserve sometimes or was this just
suppressed because you were on the birth
control pill so we see it impact some of
the hormone testing that we can do and I
think that's an important distinction
and we can see that the longer you take
it that
potentially it might actually improve
your fertility if you had underlying
endometriosis or some medical conditions
that we see associated with infertility
so prolonged pill users can potentially
improve their fertility versus people
who are trying to get pregnant that same
age who were not on on the pill those
studies are complicated right because of
selection bias because if you've been on
the pill for 10 years you're a little
bit older so is it that they were
preventing pregnancy and the other group
potentially had some exposure so they
were inherently more infertile than the
group that was on the pill but we do
know that the pill doesn't cause
infertility and I use it all the time
all the time in IVF Cycles we put people
on the birth control pill because we can
actually synchronize that group of eggs
that comes out of the Vault grow
together because your body doesn't want
to have 20 babies at one time right and
what we're trying to do with IVF get 20
eggs to grow if that's what's out of the
Vault really goes against the check and
balance of the human body to not have 20
babies at once why is it that males who
take testosterone synthetic testosterone
it shuts down their own testosterone
production and sperm production but
females who take estrogen in the form of
birth control pills it doesn't shut down
estrogen production by the ovaries so I
love this question you know the answer
so I like it extra because I know you're
asking spermatogenesis is a constant and
ongoing process right so in women you're
born with all the eggs you're ever going
to have and what we're talking about is
if we stop FSH at that moment we're just
impacting the ability to ovulate at that
time but we're not changing this
constant loss throughout the Vault
spermatogenesis right the sperm is made
every single day you're making brand new
sperm so 72 days for the sperm to be
created in the testes 18 days to find
their way out the ejaculatory system and
so exposures that you have that stop the
production of FSH and LH inhibit the
development the creation of new sperm so
somebody who's been on
testosterone will tell the brain the
brain doesn't know it's from your taking
it it says hey we have plenty of sperm
we're good we don't need anymore so the
brain then gets suppressed and doesn't
make that FSH and LH therefore not
stimulating
both further testosterone production
because you don't need that but
testosterone production and sperm
production go hand in hand so therefore
you're no longer making new sperm and in
fact the longer you're on testosterone
the harder it may be to get sperm
production to come back and in 25% of
people they may not get it back if
they've been on prolonged testosterone
exposure so it's really because of what
women will sometimes say is unfair which
is the fact that you're born with all
these eggs and you run out of them they
accumulate the wear and tear of your
life right we see egg quality being a
huge issue in female reproduction yet
men get to have new sperm every 90 days
they get to wash away whatever bad Deeds
they did and can change their lifestyle
and their exposures and have very
different sperm but because of that same
process things that shut off the
production of FSH LH really impact sperm
quite
significantly you mentioned bad Deeds um
for sperm um not by sperm I said for
sperm um and you know we we know that
heat is is a uh you know a pretty
traumatic insult to the um to the
spermatogenesis cycle um saunas and hot
tubs and whatnot and I did receive the
question as to whether or not um heat
exposure saunas hot tubs Etc are they um
detrimental to ovulation or egg
production in any way I mean obviously
things are more internal in females the
ovaries are internal but is there any
evidence for that I mean the body does
heat up yeah there's no it doesn't harm
the ovulatory period or the ovaries and
just like we know the reason why the
testes are so susceptible is because
they're supposed to be at a cooler
temperature that's why they're in the
scrotum outside the body that's why the
testes are so susceptible to heat
changes but the ovaries being inside the
body they're not in the same way now
when somebody's pregnant important
distinction right we know that the
development especially organ development
of an embryo can be more sensitive to
certain things and that heat exposure
that time whether it's hot tub use or
extreme fevers even can make a
difference in development of a fetus but
when it's coming to the ovulatory cycle
or hormone production heat in the female
doesn't make any
difference well I want to be clear
before I ask the next question that I
don't want to be responsible for any
unwanted pregnancies but when I was in
high school they told us that women can
get pregnant even while they have their
period is that true seems like a lie
based on everything you're saying but I
don't want anyone to run out and um test
that hypothesis without having the facts
first so in general if somebody has
extremely regular Cycles then that's a
complete lie you can't get pregnant on
your period the reason why they tell us
this is one especially when you're
younger your period Cycles tend to be
irregular they're not your body hasn't
fully matured to have that regularity
and that we know that sperm do live in
the repr productive tract for much
longer than the egg does so sperm can
live there for up to 5 days so if
somebody did have a shorter period
window let's say their normal periods
are going to be 24 days they're
ovulating on cycle day 10 if they have a
regular period that's five or six days
they could potentially have intercourse
that end part of that period the sperm
could live for five days and be right
there when you have the egg in route so
it's not the most fertile time for sure
and in most people that is considered a
time when you're not going to get
pregnant but especially when you're
younger and you have more irregularity
or in people who have a short cycle
window that might not be the case so by
extension um can we conclude then that
the most fertile time is going to be
when sperm meets egg let's save timing
of intercourse for yep for the time
being but because there's can be a delay
there uh when sperm meets egg um on
obviously day of ovul ation or day uh
day after day of day of the egg lives
for 24 hours so the egg can only be
fertilized for 24 hours while it's in
the fallopian tube once the egg has
entered the uterus it can't be
fertilized anymore so it has this very
short window of time where it will allow
sperm to enter it now sperm can live for
5 days so we'll say the fertile window
is this 5-day period ending on the day
of ovulation you will hear a lot of us a
lot lot of doctors say the day after
ovulation because do you really know
exactly what time you ovulate it on and
if the egg has 24 hours then that extra
day could potentially be helpful but
really it's 5 days ending on the day of
ovulation and people with very regular
Cycles or who cont trct them and they
know when that ovulation is happening
the day before and the day of ovulation
those are the two top hitting days so if
you're kind of not in the mood to have
lots of sex those are going to be the
days you target to have the highest
chance of conceiving and what is the
relationship between estrogen libido and
ovulation in females the higher your
estrogen is the increased liido that
you're going to have and of course you
see those Peak estrogen levels which are
going to trigger that LH surge so the
body is made to get pregnant you're
going to have that Peak estrogen that
Peak libido right before and right at
that ovulatory time period so that
hopefully you also want to have
intercourse and get pregnant I've heard
before let's just say that some people
be careful here um uh can sense the
literally the deployment of the of the
egg the the ovulation they they report
that they can feel yeah that this let's
just say the the departure of the of the
uh egg um is that an imaginary thing
mean I always liked I always like that
image that people can know when that
happens after all men generally know
when when their um when their sperm are
leaving their body let's hope they do um
but but um why wouldn't that there be an
internal sense for for women also of
what's going on I mean we have
interoception there's a ton of nerve
inovation of that area it doesn't
communicate to the brain excellent as
far as tracking to where that sensation
is but you're right I already said
ovulation is the rupture of a cyst right
it is rupturing and the egg is being
released and those follicular fluid is
also exiting and going into the paranal
cavity and so there is a group women who
can feel that especially people who are
very in tune with their body and it has
a name it's called middle schmerz the
pain almost feels like a crampy pain
that happens in the middle of the cycle
and that is your ovulatory pain oh
interesting what is it called middle
Schurz okay we'll put that in the show
note captions and whoever does it is
going to have to get the spelling right
middle Schurz amazing amazing um amazing
and foreign to me but for obvious
reasons uh but amazing
uh I'm always astonished in the um how
incredibly well orchestrated this whole
process is it's it's just such an
incredible feat of biology just I mean
the number of things that have to be
timed correctly and the use and I don't
want to say reuse but the the
repurposing of tissues for different
things and like it's what a what an
incredible dance it's just amazing it's
beautiful I mean I'm so nerdy because I
just love how everything has to
communicate just perfectly it makes you
in awe of the pregnancies that just
happen just all the time because really
things have to synchronize really at the
wonderful time period And even though
this isn't what we're talking about I've
heard you say this so I want to say this
people always ask every single day well
how much sex should you have when should
you have sex is there too much sex and
what we know is that you definitely
should not decrease your sexual
intercourse interval so if you are in a
relationship and you are sex everyday
people have sex every day you will 100 %
hit intercourse throughout your entire
fertile window on the day that you
ovulate you're depositing the same sperm
there because you're not generating new
sperm it's whether the load went half
and half and half and half or if it went
in you know one big group but if you're
constantly putting more sperm out there
you have a higher chance and so studies
go back and always say daily intercourse
associated with the highest chance of
fundability especially during the
fertile window
however for couples who are not sex
everyday people that idea can cause a
lot of stress stress of course impacts
the system in a lot of different ways it
can also cause sexual burnout where they
no longer feel like being intimate or
having sex on the day they're actually
ovulating because they've been doing it
this whole time leading up and that's
where the time period of saying have sex
every other day throughout the fertile
window so starting five or six days
before you think you're going to ovulate
and and then try to Target having
intercourse on the day before and the
day of ovulation and the reason why
people said every other day or a few
days prior to kind of get some sperm
exposure there in case you ovulated
early but really to try to prevent some
of that increased stress that can happen
when you're trying to conceive
especially if you have programmed or
timed intercourse that needs to happen
on an everyday interval but the odds of
getting pregnant by saving up sperm for
two or 3 days that's not higher I'm
curious then why if let's just say
hypothetically someone is um donating or
freezing sperm or doing IVF why they
instruct the male to um not ejaculate
for 48 to 72 hours prior to um let's
just say depositing sperm is such a
funny word um but it works so two points
one if we're doing a seen analysis now
we're trying to evaluate the sperm and
any test has certain normal parameters
and these are all based bed on a 48 to
72-hour abstinence period so yes if you
ejaculate more frequently you're going
to have less sperm and that can be very
normal but if we're looking at a test
with set normal parameters that are
based on two to three days of not having
intercourse that's why we want you to do
it for that if we're doing let's say IUI
or uterine insemination also known as
artificial insemination or where we take
the sperm and put it in a catheter and
put it in the uterus
we're trying to get more players further
down the field and in that case I know
when you ovulate because I'm timing it
perfectly and I am trying to get as many
possible in this process because we're
not just having them deposited in the
vagina we're trying to get them further
so we want more because that's part of
that treatment process and similarly
with IVF I want to have as many sperm as
possible to sort through and pick out
the best looking the most modal the most
normally shaped ones so we're trying to
get just a better sample and by having
these normal guidelines we're able to
judge this is low for what it should be
which can also be a clue to other
problems I definitely want to talk about
chemistry both um sort of interpersonal
chemistry and literally uh ejaculate and
vaginal chemistry but before we do that
um I'm curious whether or not we can
just touch on a few of the things that a
lot of people wonder about in terms of
egg quality and if they touch on sperm
quality maybe we can also just mention
that um but for instance um does
cannabis either by edible or by smoking
cannabis impact Ed quality in either
direction uh alcohol would be the next
and then I'm going to assume and I have
to do this strictly because of what I
understand about you know drugs of abuse
like cocaine and amphetamine
methamphetamine that none of those can
be good for systems of the body because
they provide they create so much stress
for the body um but let's just say
alcohol H in cannabis um I read a
statistic when researching the episode
on cannabis that shocked me which is
that 15% one
five% not 1.5 15% of American women at
least in this one study survey reported
having consumed or smoked cannabis
during known pregnancy which is wild
wild unless of course I'm just naive and
THC is not harmful to fetus but I have a
hard time believing that so what gives I
mean here we and and there I actually
just threw in fetal development so is
cannabis is Al alcohol bad for egg
quality so they're different things and
they're the same thing in one so let's
answer them each individually so we'll
go with the one that everybody knows and
has accepted now that they wouldn't have
accepted 40 years ago right smoking
cigarettes so that's obviously bad
decreases the number of eggs you have in
the vault smoking cigarettes actually
gets into your Vault decreases is the
number that you have you have a higher
chance of going into menopause earlier
and it increases the risk of having
abnormal chromosomes which is what we
really think about when we think about
egg quality right impacting those myotic
spindles inside the eggs which hold the
chromosomes in their perfect position
they are associated they get wear and
tear from things that cause inflammation
or are toxic so cigarette smoke we know
decreases egg quality egg quantity
increases miscarriage and then of course
has fetal impacts could I just ask you
because when we talk about um there's
nicotine which itself is not
carcinogenic and then there's the
smoking process which brings in a bunch
of other things the the question I know
is burning in everybody's mind is vaping
yeah right because vaping is I'm I'm
very bullish on this I mean it's very
clear that the chemicals associated with
vaping are just oh so bad for
Everybody's Health but it's distinctly
different from saying that nicotine is
bad for one's health and it can be but
um without doing too much of a deep dive
is are there any data that show that
vaping is bad for egg quality of course
there's not as much data because it just
hasn't been around as long but yes
vaping definitely has chemicals that
looks like it's associated with poor
success rates in IVF cycles and that's
really kind of one of the most finite
measures of egg quality we can see
because we're really testing the egg at
a level in a lab versus just are you
getting pregnant naturally and sorry to
interject again but anytime a
conversation like this comes up
especially between two people in the
health science space um there are these
shouts because I hear them literally
where people say well listen I Vaped
every day and I've had three healthy
babies and I think that my response is
always okay there's going to be a
distribution of responses and then of
course how much healthier could your
babies have been had you not Vaped
during pregnancy or Vaped prior to
pregnancy or I mean I think these are
the the key issues that like you can't
you can't rewind the clock as far as I
know right in the absence of a Time
machine you can't rewind the clock so um
I mean basically everything you're
saying is that smoking cigarettes or
vaping nicotine just can't be good for
egg quality we know that we know that
it's not good for getting pregnant we
know that it's not good for sperm and
therefore we also know it's going to
impact pregnancy rates you know things
like cannabis right decreases sperm
production decreases sperm motility
changes sperm morphology the shape of it
changes the DNA it increases the
fragmentation of the DNA
if your partner uses cannabis and you
get pregnant you have a higher chance of
miscarriage because of the sperm
association with the Cannabis now edible
cannabis as well as right because you
can't study something that's illegal so
a lot of this data is just more new and
a lot of it's going to be observational
and in States like Colorado and
California where you know canvas is
essentially legal um yeah I I'm assuming
that there are more data but okay so um
smoking
Endor vaping nicotine cannabis either
edible or smoked very likely detrimental
to egg quality and sperm quality which
is not to say that one can't conceive it
just means that the quality of your baby
your child will not be as high as the
quality of that baby if you didn't do
that is that right yes and I'm and I'm
not trying to demonize anyone that did
did do this during pregnancy a lot of
people didn't know but this is this is
really about people trying to make
choices in anticipation of future
pregnancy yeah and when you're trying to
set yourself up for Success because we
know infertility becoming more common we
don't always know who is going to have
it and when you find yourself in that
position specifically you now want to
optimize everything you can so if
there's something that is going to make
the sperm quality worse and the Egg
quality worse and your success with
treatment lower and your miscarriage
rate higher we're going to recommend
that you not do it if you're trying to
get pregnant naturally all these things
correlate over but of course there's
always going to be outliers and
exceptions I'm going to sit here and
tell you that the odds of getting
pregnant at age 43 are less than 3% per
month and every single person is going
to be like but my Aunt Barbara or I know
this person who did because 3% is not
zero and you're talking about natural
pregnancy there by by uh interc old
fashioned way yes right but yes so
people will get pregnant people will
have healthy children who do have
exposures to nicotine to cannabis even
to alcohol even though we know that
alcohol can cause fetal alcohol syndrome
0% of alcohol should be the acceptable
level in pregnancy and then does alcohol
impact fertility such a complicated
question and this is probably due to the
amount you consume and the frequency of
which you consume it alcohol is a toxin
that your liver must filter out and We
Know It causes inflammation anybody
who's had a fun night with alcohol knows
they can wake up the next day and they
feel different
their body is processing that alcohol
and that inflammation especially if it's
chronic chronic
exposure we know chronic inflammation is
one of the things that we see impacting
egg quality and sperm quality so
certainly if you enjoy alcohol it should
be something that is done in moderation
one or two drinks a week at the most and
you should not do it at all once you
find out you're pregnant I'd like to
take a quick break and thank our sponsor
insid tracker inside tracker is a
personalized nutrition platform that
analyzes data from your blood and DNA to
help you better understand your body and
help you reach your health goals I've
long been a believer in getting regular
blood work done for the simple reason
that many of the factors that impact
your immediate and long-term Health can
only be assessed with a quality blood
test the problem with a lot of blood and
DNA tests out there however is that
they'll give you information about
certain lipid markers or hormone markers
but no information about what to do with
all of that data inside tracker makes it
very easy to look at your levels of
hormones metabolic factors lipids Etc
and then to assess what sorts of
Behavioral nutritional supplementation
or perhaps other interventions you might
want to use in order to bring those
numbers into the ranges that are optimal
for your health inside tracker's
ultimate plan now includes three new
hormone markers that are critical to
measure during a woman's reproductive
and menopausal years these are estradi
progesterone and thyroid stimulating
hormone if you'd like to try insid
tracker you can go to insid tracker.com
huberman to get 20% off any of insid
track plans again that's insid
tracker.com huberman to get 20% off when
we were talking about birth control I
unfortunately moved us forward and and
forgot to ask about iuds oh yeah so my
understanding is that the copper IUD
works by creating a sort of um not
actually electric but a kind of a
electric um fence that kills sperm like
sperm don't like copper sperm don't like
copper copper likes to kill sperm um
there's some interesting uh history I've
been reading a lot on the history of
Medicine of um people who you know for
whatever reason were forced into or
chose to be in the sex trade prostitutes
using um inserting copper coins into
their vaginal tract to try and uh kill
sperm but to varying degrees of success
obviously there's a whole um
socioeconomic landscape around that so
um I think it's obvious what I'm
referring to but um very interesting but
that's just one form of IUD right there
there are some other iuds and then
there's of course the ring we didn't
talk about that so maybe we just touch
on a few of those in within the context
of whether or not it Alters egg quality
Andor future fertility when one takes
the ring out takes the IUD out this is a
great question because a lot of people
don't know this and and I'll roll
through a few of the top birth control
methods and just thinking through copper
IUD as you already said no hormonal
involvement it causes inflammation and a
toxic environment inside the uterus
isolated does cause sometimes heavier
periods but they should still be regular
if they are irregular that's a sign of a
hormonal issue because you still ovulate
with the copper IUD is it literally a
copper wire woven into the so the I well
the IUD is a is a little T and the arms
are have copper wires wrapped around
them and they and those are they grow
into the uterine lining they don't grow
into the uterine lining the IUD just
sits in there and just the presence of
that copper causes that inflammatory
reaction in that toxic environment and
is it toxic to the environment in ways
that are detrimental to the woman or or
just a sperm both I mean implantation is
not going to
occur likely right I mean no nothing has
100% successful but it's much harder for
an embryo to implant within that highly
inflammatory environment to me amazing
that people figured this out before
fting Laboratories right let's just put
some copper in some uteruses and see
what happens right you know it I it
really speaks to the the urgency that
must have existed to preventing
pregnancy and they just how costly
biologically and a pregnancy is
pregnancy is and pregnancy is not Health
neutral so it is something that somebody
needs to be in of right health or it can
be a deadly circumstance when we get
back to other iuds so iuds that more
people are more familiar with are the
progesterone based iuds this is going to
be your Marena Kina liletta they have a
bunch of different names based on the
amount of progesterone and how long they
last for these work mostly by thinning
out the uterine lining as we already
said progesterone
compacts the uterine lining to prepare
it for implantation in a normal cycle
but if you have constant exposure to
Progesterone what is going to happen is
it's going to prevent the uterine lining
from growing and it gets it very very
thin not all iuds in fact most of them
don't prevent ovulation only in about
50% of people do they actually prevent
ovulation so their main mechanism of
action is this endometrial effect when
you remove the IUD
especially if you're already ovulating
no problem the problem we do see in some
people with progesterone iuds that maybe
isn't talked about as much is that this
prolonged progesterone exposure because
people are putting iuds in for 5 to
seven years and not having a period for
that length of time because the
endometrium has become so atropic or
non-existent that you're no longer
bleeding despite the fact that you may
be
ovulating it can take a while for that
lining to grow back and so it's not
uncommon to have an IUD in place and if
you have no period you're going to say
this is great I don't have a period
wonderful you get it removed and now
your period hasn't come back and that
leads people to sometimes be concerned
that the IUD is causing them not to
ovulate or they have
this infertility caused by the IUD but
really what it is is that the Linings
become so so thin that it can take many
months of that unopposed estrogen
exposure in the follicular phase to get
it thick enough to finally bleed when
you're ovulating so I do tell people if
they have a progesterone IUD to get it
removed 3 to six months before they want
to get pregnant use some other form of
contraception but give their body time
to make sure they have that regular
period pattern back important
distinction if you're still ovulating
and having a period on an IUD then this
is going to be less of a concern because
if you're growing enough of a lining to
then shed it we're less worried about it
but if you are amaric or have absence of
your periods with an IUD we need to
think about removing it for a period of
time before you get pregnant so that
your body can grow that lining again
when it comes to some of the other
things that you mentioned one I you
didn't ask that I want to mention is the
Depo pra shot the Depo pra shot is a
high dose of progesterone high enough to
actually prevent ovulation so in that
circumstance you are not ovulating and
therefore if you don't ovulate at you're
not going to get pregnant Depo pra is
proven to prevent ovulation for 3 months
so when you take it you need to get it
every 3 months to have a proven
contraceptive benefit however it can
last in your system for 18 months and
prevent ovulation for up to 18 months so
I will see people who liked that option
for contraception and now they haven't
had a period in a long time but their
last Depo shot was 6 months ago and
there are all frustrated by the fact
when I tell them well you still may not
have another period for a year plus
because this high level of progesterone
that you've already injected into your
system can last a substantial amount of
time so that is a contraceptive option
that I tell people to discontinue a year
and a half to two years before they want
to get pregnant which sometimes people
don't know that yet and so that's
something that can be a contraceptive
option from if you're very remote from
wanting to have a child but in people
who are in their childbearing years
contemplating family building
soon that is not my favorite option so
you haven't mentioned because I haven't
asked um any negative consequences of
birth control of any kind and I'm not
encouraging you to if you don't believe
in them I know that this is a very
controversial um topic but um you know
one of the more popular studies
discussed on social media is one that I
I've spent some time with the paper um
and a few of the papers that stemmed
from it um not a huge study but
describing that how women rate the faces
of men as either more essentially what
happens is there there seems to be at
least in this study a there was a a
statistically significant um bias uh for
women to select particular male faces as
attractive and those male faces tended
to be of the more you know square jaw
AKA masculine features right in a quotes
right this is what the study um found um
but that when women were on oral
contraception presumably estrogen
progestin type oral contraception that
that effect um was smeared they had a
not a statistically significant tendency
to uh choose the quote unquote more
masculine faces I have to be very
careful with my language here because
you know it's easy to get description of
a study like this wrong and that has led
a lot of people to think that birth
control is going to throw off their
partner choice
um now of course it's a small study um
studies like it are not always so well
controlled um but is there any evidence
that birth control oral oral estrogen
progestin based birth control just to
keep it specific can increase rates of
cancers can decrease rates of cancers
can lead to um any sorts of disruptions
in um bodily uh function or health
that's really like a rock solid result
that's been seen by mult multiple
studies clinical trials um or are we
still just in the dark about a lot of
this stuff okay so nothing is without
risk getting pregnant is not without
risk taking the birth control pill is
not without risk we do see that there's
been a lot of not informed consent and
people who are taking the birth control
pill meaning maybe they weren't educated
about what all of their options were the
positives and the negatives about each
one of them if we're going to reference
the combo to the pill estrogen
progesterone pill important to
understand that neither the estrogen nor
the progesterone are the same estrogen
progesterone that your ovaries make
right it's ethanol estradi which your
brain interprets as an estrogen but
other parts of your body may not and
then it's various types of progestins
some of which have even androgenic or
male hormone likee properties and some
of which do not so there's a ton of
variation even the amount of ethanol
estrad that each pill has with your low
low and your low low pills having less
and even with the modern-day average
pill having a lot less estrogen than it
used to when you're on the birth control
pill your ovaries aren't making
estradiol and that estradiol is
important in growing the uterine lining
but also for the genital structures and
so we think about vaginal health and
bulvar health we certainly see that
especially with continuous use so if we
distinguish you take the P for 21 days
and you have a 7-Day break where you
might bleed or you take sugar pills and
then you take them again a lot of people
now are taking continuously where you
have exposure to these compounds every
single day H so in in like the the um
the wheel the little little pouch with a
wheel of different colored pills um may
have seen these on the on the countertop
in previous relationships um and then
there's the ones that sometimes people
just opt not to take because those are
the not the placebo like there's no need
to take estrogen during that phase and
then and then they repeat is that
exactly okay but some people are taking
estrogen all way very common right now
so people and they're not wrong they say
oh well why have a period in these
little breaks it's not really a
reflection of my hormone status which is
accurate and so they're taking them
continuously you also have less pill
failure pregnancies so if you're using
the pill for contraception that can be a
great strategy but the longer you take
them we do see some vaginal involv art
changes right and so atrophic vaginitis
people who notice increased sensitivity
decreased elasticity increase discomfort
with intercourse increase in like yeast
infections that can sometimes be see
because that environment is different
now that's just one thing that can come
from the pill we also see the pill be
life saving for other people they have
terrible you know PMS or premenstrual
dysphoric syndrome where their mental
health when they change from from high
to low estrogen it's always the change
in estrogen that interferes can cause
some people to really have mental health
issues that are so severe that having
that stable hormone level is helpful and
so the pill can be extremely beneficial
for some people when it comes to mental
health it can be beneficial for people
who have issues with very heavy periods
and anemia instead of getting blood
transfusions you know taking the birth
control pill might prevent the lining of
the uterus from growing so much that
they bleed so much same with fibroids
people with PCOS PCOS is polycystic
ovarian syndrome if we want to put it
very simply you have a lot of eggs in
your Vault so you release a lot of eggs
every month and what this does is the
FSH signal gets diluted and so you're
not responding to the normal signal and
you don't ovulate and because the ovary
is a hormone making factory it gets
really bored when it can't make estrogen
because that egg's not growing so it
starts to make testosterone so you start
to see this Androgen dominant
environment associated with lack of
ovulation and having a lot of follicles
inside the ovary that are not really
responding an androgen excuse me
androgenization of other tissues like
like body hair deepening of voice body
hair typically the level of testosterone
made in PCOS isn't truly deepening voice
it can if there is an ovarian tumor
making testosterone or certain other
conditions but typically with PCOS you
see increase in body hair increase in
acne
and you can see some even like male
pattern balding some temporal balding of
women so some hair loss temporal B so
like the the WID yeah the Widow peaking
and then thinning out in these two areas
and then we see an increase in body
composition towards a male level so if
we think about a male body holding your
fat in your abdominal region and if we
think about the traditional female body
holding more fat in the hips and thighs
area we see that when this hormone
shifts in PCOS you tend to get more
abdominal fat distribution which then
leads to further insulin resistance and
metabolic syndrome but in PCOS because
you're not
ovulating
and those ovaries each little follicle
makes a tiny amount of estrogen we'll
say each little follicle when it's not
responding will make you know one to two
peagrams of estrogen but if you have 50
of them each month you're having some
constant estrogen exposure so that
lining of the uterus is being constantly
stimulated to grow and you're never
getting the progesterone to stabilize or
the progesterone withdraw to bleed so
endometrial cancer is much higher in
people with PCOS who don't ovulate and
the birth control pill can prevent that
any unopposed estrogen situation because
the body is made to have both estrogen
and progesterone so we see an immense
decrease in endometrial cancer an
immense drop in ovarian cancer ovarian
cancer comes from the remodeling of the
ovary so every time you have a follicle
grow and it ruptures and it makes takes
the Corpus ludum and then it heals up
those are opportunities for those cancer
cells to go away in that remodeling
process and lead to ovarian cancer and
because you're not ovulating on the pill
your incidence of ovarian cancer drops
dramatically 10 years of pel use has
dropped the chance you get ovarian
cancer by more than 90% And of course
ovarian cancer is super hard to diagnose
because the inovation to the peritoneal
system is is poor and you don't have any
outward signs often to late stage
disease that being
said could you potentially have an
increase in breast cancer in some people
by taking the Pill by taking the pill
that that's a concern especially in
people who might be predisposed to this
for some other reason they might have
braa mutations or something like that um
and then is there a situation where the
pill certainly masks what's going on
with your menstrual cycle and I really
think this is where where Women's Health
had has a huge history in paternalism
meaning doctors would just tell people
this is what you're going to do so your
periods are irregular here is the birth
control pill and they're not explaining
why or the pros and cons to it and what
happens is people are not being taught
how their bodies work and now they are
because of your podcast amongst others
and now they're able to know that my
periods of Vital sign and I don't know
what it is because the pill is producing
a different environment the pill's also
been associated with potentially
development of things like leaky gut or
IBS and so there is a definite change in
your environment when you're on the
birth control pill increase risk of
blood clots because of how it's
processed in the liver increasing your
clotting factors can I just interrupt
there you know I'm aware um that a a
fair Fairly high percentage of people
have um mutations in Factor 5 lien a
clotting Factor um few where people are
as we say homozygous have two deficient
copies or mutant copies I should say um
but there are many people out there that
have one mutant copy of factor 5 lien
and my understanding is that oral
contraception in females um can really
exacerbate the factor 5 lien mutation do
you suggest that people get um get their
Factor five lien um genetics analyzed I
mean it's pretty inexpensive to do right
I think on a standard blood test you can
just ask for the factor 5 um analysis
and it's not like a a really in-depth
thing you don't have to fly to yeah you
don't have to fly you don't have to fly
to another country you know like you do
for many things um it's important to say
that's not the norm right like that's
not the recommendation when you're
talking about putting somebody on the
birth control pill you want to make sure
they don't have high blood pressure
because it can increase their blood
pressure you want to make sure they
don't smoke cigarettes because the
combination of the pill and cigarette
smoking can increase the risk of a
stroke but the recommendation is not to
screen them to see if they have any
inherited clotting disorders that said
if you ever have a blood clot on the
birth control pill because you're
traveling on a plane or you're just on
the pill or you're living your life
you're now going to get this extensive
work up to find out if you do have that
it's by no means wrong and specifically
you should if anybody in your family has
ever had a DVT so a deep vein thrombosis
so blood caught in their leg or a
pulmonary embolism or a PE so anybody in
your family has had one of those you
should have 100% get worked up for
clotting disorders and if you have
something like you carry Factor 5 you
should no longer take the birth control
pill and specifically the pill because
it's an oral pill and how it's
metabolized in the liver is actually
what is causing the change in those
clotting factors because that's where
they're made as well so it doesn't mean
you can't take any form of contraception
but we do want to make sure that we
counsel you appropriately I never think
it's wrong to be an advocate for your
own health or to ask questions it's
important to know that screening I mean
I'll get on my soap box because we'll
talk about screening for ovarian reserve
and it is 100% not recommended even
though I think it should be yeah my next
question was going to be about testing
amh levels and um and we'll return to
that for those that hear that and it
sounds cryptic as well as getting an
ultrasound just seeing basically how
many how many eggs are are in likely to
be in in the Vault on on both sides okay
so we have to remember that screening
recommendations come from at what point
in the population does it make sense to
spin the money to test for a disease
based on the likelihood of finding it so
if we think about right that's what your
papsmear guidelines and your colonoscopy
and your mammograms everything is all
based on when are you going to find
enough cases at some age to make it
worthwhile testing which is a crazy
principle especially in the US because
the government's not paying for our
health care so why should these
guidelines be based on when is it coste
effective to do testing well I I'll put
in a this is going to sound sound a
little bit conspiratorial but it's not I
mean I think that given that for people
who have insurance private paid
insurance or through their work um that
there's a cost to doing these tests of
any kind colonoscopy amh Etc and they
must have figured out the you know
optimal point on the graph with which
they can reduce their payout to people
who for instance get colon cancer if
they didn't get the colonoscopy at 45 as
opposed to 50 as opposed to 60 as
opposed to 25 I mean this is I mean the
reality we know is that
the more information you have the better
choices you can make I mean the only
caveat to that would be that uh for some
not all but for some people sort of of
the hypochondria type sometimes more
information leads to more anxiety which
leads to more problems but that's a rare
instance that is I always think that in
general data is always good age having
the information at hand about your body
and being able to make educated choices
versus being in a position where you say
I had no idea that I had Factor 5 Li in
and I had this terrible blood clot
because pulmonary emms can kill people
we all know that right so we talk about
this rare thing but it can happen but
this is really where it can be tough it
can be tough to find even a doctor who
made like we said Factor five is a blood
test and relatively inexpensive so that
one is not hard but Physicians live in a
weird world where you know they have
recommendations based on screening based
on the likelihood of finding disease
that they follow and when they go off of
those they start introducing themselves
to why are you not following medical
guidelines but for an
individual this is really tough to
advocate for yourself and the one thing
that I'll say too this is why paying
attention to your body is so important
right understanding your stool habits
and what's normal and what's not so that
you can catch early signs of things and
present for that colonoscopy earlier the
current screening guideline for should
you get your ovarian reserve checked is
that you should not ACOG the American
College of OBGYN has an entire practice
bullettin situation saying there's no
utility and screening for amh okay I
mean I totally disagree but I'm glad you
disagree I mean to me it just seems nuts
I mean um or ovaries rather I mean the
um the amh is a blood draw amh is a
blood test it's a blood draw it one
could opt to do the um ultrasound as
well which is of course more invasive
but but women who are seeing their OBGYN
are probably familiar with with with um
pelvic exams yeah I mean it's a FAL
ultrasound but it's not painful not
painful um but different than a blood
draw just just for in full disclosure so
um and you know I've heard of women in
their early 30s going in getting their
am levels checked getting their
ultrasound and then going oh my goodness
they're down to like you know I I don't
want to throw out numbers cuz this
actually can get tricky it um you know
they'll say oh you have whatever you
know four follicles and then someone in
their early 40s will have 20 follicles
and then people start to is it sort of
becomes a scorekeeping thing and and of
course follicle quality there a bunch of
other things um and then you can tell us
more about those but let's say someone
did not have insurance or or Insurance
permission to um to get this paid for
what is the approximate cost of getting
one's amh levels and analyzed $79 $79 to
find out essentially where your ovarian
reserve is at so let's talk about this I
already said this in my soap box so ACOG
says you shouldn't screen it because amh
does not predict your fundability right
your body's ability to get pregnant in
that month is independent of your amh
and for the most part that's true right
because let's say you have a person and
they're both 30 you have two people one
has low ovarian reserve they have five
eggs coming out of the Vault and this
one has normal ovarian reserve and they
have 20 eggs coming out of the Vault and
we should probably clarify that the
number of because you said this earlier
but the number of eggs coming out of the
vault is an indirect measure of how many
eggs is in the vault when that number is
going down it means the number of eggs
in the vault is likely going down down
corre sort of like your body starts to
take smaller withdrawals as you start to
run out of the Vault wants to be at like
equilibrium right it really wants to be
in this Middle Ground so when you have
too many it shoots out more every month
it's too crowded it doesn't want that
and then when it starts to get low it
gets scared about being empty and sends
out fewer per month so what you see
outside the Vault and that is called an
anal follicle count or an AFC it's an
ultrasound based measurement of how many
eggs you have outside the vault at one
point in time and on the ultrasound if
one looks um this is going to show up as
so what look like um little Hollow
spaces like so not gray stuff but but
Hollow Bodies I say chocolate chips and
the chocolate chip cookie if we can
imagine the over yeah like looks like a
chocolate chip cookie the chocolate
chips
small little dark fluid fill follicles
each one of those houses an egg some
bigger than others because they're more
mature than others based on when you
check in the cycle so if you're looking
in that early follicular phase when
somebody's on their period they're they
all should be small because nothing's
been stimulated if I'm looking per
ulatory I'll see that dominant follicle
that's about to ovulate and then
everything else will be small and is
there a a graph that people can look at
or that we could link to that says okay
the the average with a distribution of
you know standard error on their side
for let's say a 28-year-old woman or a
37y old woman or a 45y old woman of the
number of follicles on the right and
left side and as I understand
asymmetries are common yeah um tends to
be you know like if someone goes in and
they you got six follicles on the left
side and 12 on the other side are they
how do how do people gauge what what
fantas points one because their doctors
should tell them but that doesn't always
happen but yes we we add these counts
together to get your anro follicle count
because there is often asymmetry but
what we should expect let's say in
somebody who's 30 is you should have in
the 16 to 20 range of total follicles
per month right and left side combined
comined okay when you're 35 that number
is closer to like 14 to 16 so starting
to drop it's still pretty good when
you're 40 it's 8 to 10 when you're 44 2
to 4 right so you start to have this
immense drop that exponentially starts
to increase really around AG 37 so
things start to kind of get into this
severe Zone really after age 37 and we
didn't really talk about ages 18 to 25
but there are people who get pregnant in
that age bracket are is the follicle
count very very high is there sort of an
a is a nonlinear drop off or yeah their
follicle count would be higher and I
mean I occasionally have patients who
are very young but have infertility or
want to freeze their eggs I've also had
patients in that age range who are in
premature ovarian failure right right
because there can be things that go
wrong even early but we should probably
highlight again something that you said
earlier but gosh I you know this like
contradicts so much of what's out there
which is that even if you have low
follicle count if you collect eggs
you're not changing what's in the vault
you're not pulling From the Vault you're
not you can't right that those eggs are
spent you you you now have the
opportunity to turn them into potential
pregnancies correct I mean side note
right we haven't even dove into IVF but
that's the next wave of technology is
what we call IVM in vitro maturation are
trying to figure out how can you get
eggs from the Vault and get them to grow
in the lab because that would open up
possibilities for people who have fewer
eggs to have a higher efficiency of this
process because one of the limiting
factors when you're doing fertility when
you're doing egg freezing or IVF is how
many eggs can you get per month and
that's why some people have to do cycle
after cycle because they can only get
five eggs or five eggs but if we Circle
back to what we were saying when we got
off on this beautiful tangent is that no
no matter if you have five or you have
20 eggs outside the Vault you're
ovulating one so you're trying to get
pregnant naturally that's what
fundability is probability of getting
pregnant per month naturally you have
the same chance if you're the same age
regardless of if you have five eggs or
you have 20 eggs and that's why ACOG
came in and said well amh doesn't impact
fundability it doesn't predict your
ability to get pregnant or who's going
to have infertility and who's not going
to have infertility so there's no
utility and screening for it
in people now for once I'm speechless I
mean that that argument makes sense
through the lens of just probabilities
of
pregnancy um through natural conception
um but it completely erases the very
very very real situation where people
are making choices about for instance
whether or not to stay with a given
partner whether or not to leave a given
partner whether or not to accelerate the
process of building a family my egg
should I have a baby now goodness like
there's so many
this American College of whoever whoever
is like
completely but they're crazy and that's
what I say they they argue in their
statement that finding that you have
sorry I'm like reeling it in I mean
think trying to think of an analogy that
doesn't fail but it's like if you can
it's like saying okay if you can walk
now great there's no reason to test for
this inevitable paralysis that's going
to happen at different rates in
different people and there are things
that you can do to offset in other words
you could like take a little bit of some
tissue that will allow you to walk in
the future but we're not going to do
that because if you can walk now you can
walk now it's good now that's absurd and
that's really what it is and they say
well finding out that you have low
ovarian reserve at a young age is going
to cause undue stress that is
unwarranted because most people don't
have infertility and so they're purely
putting it through the lens of your
likelihood to get pregnant but it's
actionable stress exactly right if it
were just stress like hey guess what and
you know I know people who have family
members with Huntington mutations and
some opt to not know whether or not they
themselves have have the Huntington
mutation and and it's a very personal
choice right sure but here that whereas
unfortunately there still isn't a a cure
for Huntington hopefully someday there
will be malom would but in the meantime
there's essentially a a cure for this
situation which is the Harvest and
potential fertilization there at least
an opportunity and this is what I say
and of course you and I feel similarly
education and data like being the one to
make the choice way is an extremely
important distinction versus having it
happen to you so if you're young and you
find out you have low ovarian reserve is
that going to make a difference and it
very well might you might now freeze
your eggs when you wouldn't have
otherwise you might now start to try to
get pregnant if you're partnered when
you otherwise were just waiting but
change the conversation with your
partner too right because a lot of
people think they can just wait I you be
like because of age right we're in
totally wait but if you have a low
ovarian reserve then that you may lose
the opportunity for Parenthood and for a
lot of people this is a life goal and
this is what's Wild to me when on earth
besides reproduction do we have life
goals that we take the approach I'll
just wait and see if it's a problem
later never right if you want to become
a doctor you want to become an athlete
you are constantly working towards that
goal or understanding what it's going to
take to get there but why does the goal
of Parenthood the attitude is completely
I'm not going to think about it until
later and then I'll deal with it if it
becomes a problem because you can make
change choices you could freeze your
eggs you could try to get pregnant
sooner you could evaluate for reasons of
low ovarian reserve do you have a
genetic mutation or an autoimmune
disease why is it low it's not just
always a big unknown there can be some
actual things that potentially might be
impactful for your health long term so I
think it's it's wild that this is the
current conversation and I will say I
know personally a lot of OBGYN who 100%
will draw an amh blood test if you're at
your annual and you ask and I recommend
all of my OB friends because I see
people at a different stage right when
they see me they're struggling to get
pregnant or they want to freeze their
eggs but when we talk about this I say
hey just like you say are you trying to
get pregnant now and if somebody says no
and follow-up question is well do you
want to be on birth control the same
question should be well do you want to
be pregnant at some point and if so
should you consider freezing your eggs
or getting this blood test checked and
very often people will make a different
decision with that information well I'm
so glad that you're highlighting this
because my understanding is at least in
the state of California I don't know
about other states or if it even varies
by state that the opportunity to harvest
eggs uh and freeze them um there's a
hard cut off at age I think it is 42
prior to age 42 they'll do it um after
42 they'll do it if and only if you're
willing to do invitro fertilization to
actually fertilize and then they'll
freeze embryos but they're far more
reluctant to collect eggs after age 42
yes yes and no so when you think about
egg freezing and IVF are really the same
process right when you're going through
the exact same thing you're taking the
eggs out of the body and then you're
either just freezing them as an egg or
you're fertilizing them in the lab and
that's IVF and making an embryo right
away egg freezing has changed
dynamically over the past 10 years
whereas 10 years ago survival rate of
eggs in the lab was 40% really terrible
and so we really didn't offer it to many
people it wasn't something that was
talked about and now it feels trendy
almost but it's really just the tech has
gotten so much better and cheaper yeah
90% of eggs now survive the free thaw so
90% is not a low number by any means
embryos are much stronger right an egg
is a single cell it's a single cell an
embryo when we freeze an embryo that's
day five or six is 300 plus cells so
it's so much stronger and those embryos
survive the freeze thought 99% of the
time so yes there's a 9% difference that
being said making embryos is a lot more
expensive eggs is cheaper you could do
two rounds of eggs and have just as many
eggs or have more eggs than if you'd
made them into embryos right away so I
never recommend that somebody commits to
a sperm source that they don't want to
have a child with unless that that's the
sperm Source they want to have a child
and this has changed because when embryo
survival was so much greater than egg
survival especially if you had few eggs
or you were older making embryos was the
only option what we do know is that egg
quality decreases immensely as we get
older and we've touched on this but we
haven't really mentioned it so not only
do you have fewer eggs as you get older
the chromosomes inside start to lose
their positioning and so we think about
egg quality we think about genetic
normaly and we know that the rates of
anupy or abnormal chromosomes increases
proportionally to your age which um for
people that aren't aware are going to
predispose not always um to miscarriages
if they're implanted or potentially even
uh the formation of a of a fetus that
carries for instance tricomes so CH
chromosomal repeats or um lack of lack
of certain chromosomes these could be
deadly or they could be um capable of
carrying to term and then but have
undetectable Demi to severe
developmental um abnormalities correct
correct and this is this is why it you
have a lower probability of pregnancy
per month as you get older so if we look
at your natural fundability it's not
because you have fewer eggs because we
already said your egg count per month
doesn't impact your probability of
getting pregnant it's because the
normaly of those chromosomes has changed
so dramatically that the odds that your
body's randomly choosing the good one to
ovulate become so low and that's why
those natural fertility rates are so low
because most genetically abnormal eggs
do not fertilize or implant but if they
do they have a significantly higher
chance of miscarriage it's 40% at age 40
right so you have a much lower chance of
seeing the positive pregnancy test but
then your chance of losing that
pregnancy is significantly higher as
well so when we are counseling somebody
about egg phrasing what we know is that
not every egg is going to fertilize with
sperm going to make an embryo going to
be genetically normal or even implant
when it is genetically normal there is
huge loss in human reproduction meaning
the more eggs you have at a younger age
the better the ROI on this process is
going to be it doesn't mean you you
don't do it when people get older but
every Clinic does have a cut off and
every Clinic is going to be a little bit
different a lot of different reasons why
we actually probably have an older cuto
off so we will let somebody go through
IVF or freeze their eggs up to age 45
and it's a lot about informed consent
and
having the approach that you're smart
enough that if I give you the odds and I
walk you through how many eggs you are
and the likelihood of them making into
embryos you can say yeah but for or 10
eggs is way more than zero based on my
circumstance and that is worth it to me
because it gives me the opportunity to
potentially have a child when otherwise
my opportunity is going to be zero so a
lot of this is rooted in paternalism
that people can't as a patient
understand these odds and they have
unrealistic
expectations I think there's a huge
shift in Reproductive Medicine to really
counseling patients and giving them
autonomy and some of these decisions but
there does become a point where there's
the likelihood of finding a normal egg
is so so low that the money or the
expense of the process doesn't make
sense and people should utilize egg
donation or other opportunities for
conception this drop in both the number
of eggs and the Egg quality they really
start to become so profound at age 37
and on and that's when we really start
to see both these things are overlapping
at the same time so if you're waiting
till age 35 36 for your first kid but
you want two or three we've got to
really look forward about is that is
that strategy makes sense well what is
your amh one are you going to run out of
eggs before then two how what other
issues could be going on is the sperm
fine are the tubes open because we are
seeing that when people start families
later when people have more chronic
illness and autoimmune disease and
obesity that it's much harder to get
pregnant and so the birth rates right
for the first time in a long time across
the board are dropping and infertility
is rising because of all of these
factors combined So based on everything
you just said and and yes I'm going to
say it a fifth time because the
misconception about this is one of the
primary reasons why people avoid
harvesting eggs it's not the only reason
but when you harvest eggs freeze them
now sounds like the viability of those
eggs is is quite quite strong compared a
few years ago uh so that's great 90% uh
recovery uh when they thaw them um is
not going to diminish the number of eggs
in the vault such a critical point um
and post age 37 there's a sounds like a
nonlinear drop off in egg quality for
most and these are averages right so
every be so the people that got pregnant
with healthy kids in their late 30s and
40s you know yes we hear you um
congratulations we're happy um but this
speaks to the kind of the the logic
anyway we're not putting any emotion or
circumstances on this but the logic of
somebody in their let's say late 20s
early 30s getting their amh levels
through a roughly $80 blood draw um and
then perhaps based on their life goals
and circumstances doing either one or
several rounds of egg collection and
freezing especially since it sounds like
you don't need to fertilize those eggs
so if one doesn't have a partner is
concerned about what they're going to do
who's who's going to be uh who's going
to provide the sperm you know um because
of course some people choose to raise
kids on their own um but parenting is a
whole other issue but um they could do
that later so that raises the questions
of what are the health risks if any um
pain levels if any and um and that
includes psychological pain of egg
Harvest I mean so going back to what you
said earlier this is going to be
injecting um synthetic mimics of FSH and
LH um follicle stimulating hormone and
luteinizing hormone maybe some growth
hormone I hear nowadays there's also the
practice of injecting um uh these are
essentially uh platelet rich plasma PRP
uh platelet rich plasma excuse me uh PRP
in perhaps even into the ovarian Vault
we can get back to that so there's a
bunch of stuff that's being done to
someone there's low stem where people
are getting like low doses of these
drugs there's High stem where it's like
a full blast Maybe you could walk us
through that procedure and just sort of
General Contour because it you know it
would require a lot of time to go
through it all in detail but is this a
horrible thing to go through is it mild
to go through is it like a walk in the
park um let let's walk through it all so
I I love this and this is my bread and
butter and this is what I do every day
studies tell us that if you are not
ready to have a family by age 32 to 33
that that is the optimal time for the
average person to intervene and freeze
their eggs it's not up for debate it's
when you have both the intersection of
still a good egg quality and Good Egg
quantity on average and so that is
younger than a lot of people are
thinking about having families and the
reason why is when we really think about
what happens to the egg afterward that's
what's really critically important so
I'm going to answer the question about
what you go through but just thinking we
already said you freeze your eggs 90% of
them are going to survive the freea
about 75% will be fertilized by sperm
and about 50% of those will even make it
to an implantation stage embryo or a
blastic we're assuming healthy sperm so
sperm sperm no DNA excessive DNA
fragmentation you already hit the nail
on the head one of the biggest issues
with egg freezing is I don't know the
future I don't know if this sperm is
going to be great or not I don't it
could be from a pot smoker just kidding
pot smokers not kidding pot smokers
we're not but we don't know right so we
have this future yet undetermined sperm
source so I am going to assume you're
going to fall average on these data
points that we're going to walk through
but the reality is you buffer the risk
by having more eggs frozen and that's
why people are going through multiple
rounds or Cycles because we don't know
we don't know how that fertilization
will be if you have 20 eggs and 18
survive the freeze thaw and 14 fertilize
and seven make it to the blasticus stage
if your age 30 we would anticipate
around 60 to 70% of them are going to be
genetically normal and you're young so
that's already kind of a big hit at that
age so let's say of the seven four of
them are genetically normal when I go to
transfer them I have at best a 65%
chance of live birth per embryo which is
really good when you put in the lens of
fundability and Peak success tends to be
closer to 20% and you're going to
implant one embryo at a time 100% we're
going to implant one embryo at a time
now does anyone ask for two people ask
for two doctors will do two it is it
lowers live birth rates if we're looking
at giving each embryo the healthiest
opportunity of becoming a baby number
one embryos with IVF have a slightly
higher chance of monozygotic twinning
right so twinning fraternal twinning
comes if you ovulate two eggs they both
get fertilized so each baby is
completely different genetically own egg
own sperm monozygotic is from an embryo
split because of the IVF process
likely putting the embryo in the
catheter maybe having that you know
outer surface touched pred disposes it
to splitting after you put it into the
body so more identical twins mono two to
3% chance of monozygotic twins with IVF
and the natural chance is 0.003% so
significantly higher even though
ultimately not a probable outcome I'm
going to have a couple patients a year
who are going to have monozygotic twins
and if I put two embryos in I've now one
taken this from a potential twin
pregnancy to a triplet or even a quad if
they both split so hence presumably like
the octomom cases and things like that
well that one they just literally put
eight embryos inside but that's a whole
I mean that's medical malpractice right
but really most the time when we're
talking about embryos we're talking
about people with infertility or people
who spent a significant amount of money
a huge portion of fertility is embryo
quality right the competency of the
embryo the genetics of the embryo it's
expensive to go through egg freezing and
IVF yet the uterine environment is
another component it doesn't make sense
to waste multiple embryos in the same
uter environment statistically it
doesn't make sense it also doesn't make
sense to make your embryos compete
against each other so will people put
one embryo into let's just say DNA Mom
right and one into surrogate mom and and
try and get two siblings um
simultaneously I've definitely done that
and had patients do that it's not common
because surrogacy using a gestational
carrier is so expensive and there's such
a limited Supply it's very hard to find
somebody who wants to go through the act
of carrying a child for somebody else
but that definitely is a strategy that
some people utilize especially if
they're older or they're concerned that
they might have a lower chance of
implantation but they want to give
themselves a try but if we look at one
embryo 65% chance of success cumulative
probability after the second is
88% okay almost everybody's pregnant
after two and these are euploid
genetically normal Embry
okay and then if you go to the third so
cumulatively after three euploid embryo
transfers each one being a single embryo
95% of people have a baby in their arms
meaning the incidence of her current
implantation failure is actually pretty
low
5% but how many normal embryos do you
need for what family size if you're
freezing your eggs because you got 20
eggs at age 30 and the example I gave
and you just made four normal embryos
right so so that's really unlikely to
make three or four kids it would it has
a really good chance of making one gives
you the opportunity for a second but
that's also presuming that everything
happened perfectly that the sperm is not
pot smoking sperm but you know what I
mean not bad quality sperm there's not
other environmental issues when it comes
to your own health when you're trying to
get pregnant or other diseases you may
have so we really need a higher number
of eggs specifically when we don't know
what the equation will truly look like
for one individual person when they go
through the process and one of the only
added benefits of embryos especially if
you are partnered if you're with
somebody who you do want to have
children with you just don't want to
have them yet is that I know the
downstream I know the number I know how
many embryos I have and if it's not
enough to give you a high chance of what
you want your family to be you can
intervene now right because by
definition with egg phrasing we're not
wanting to be pregnant for years so if
you're doing this with a partner and
you're making embryos and now I say we
only got one genetically normal embryo
you have the opportunity to choose to
either go through more cycles and store
more embryos for later to maybe try to
get pregnant sooner because there's some
underlying issue with your fertility you
can make a choice because you're falling
off the curve there could ask you a
question so this uh you mentioned age
about 32 33 in an ideal circumstance
with the finances there Etc one would
Harvest eggs unless they're already
starting a family through natural means
um what about for sperm I mean we we've
all heard the studies that uh with
increased age of the sperm that there's
a higher although still statistically
pretty small incense of things like um
Spectrum conditions um so do you
recommend to
younger males um uh men in their late
20s early 30s to freeze sperm I mean
it's never going to be wrong to save
your gametes because we don't have
crystal balls for the future right so
your gamt are your eggs and your sperm
that increase and we'll just say
negative outcome from Advanced paternal
age really starts to be seen at age 50
so most men are not looking at primarily
starting their family after that age
however what I run into all the time is
maybe you're working on a second family
or maybe life has gone down a different
pathway and now you're with a partner
who potentially is younger and wants to
conceive and you now have older sperm
having sperm in the bank is so cheap and
easy to free sperm eggs I haven't even
answered your primary question in the
process of collecting sperm well well
not entirely um without its uh issues is
is far it's embarrassing at best but
it's much simpler yeah it's much simpler
there's generally doesn't require
hormone injections although you know
maybe for rare instances where people
are hypogonadal or something but if
you're going to freeze your sperm you're
right you typically you're going to get
some blood work done because most places
that store sperm per FDA guidelines have
to make sure that if you carried an
infectious disease it's stored in a
special tank so you'll have to get blood
work done then you have to abstain for
your two to three days collect into a
cup you're done which by the way guys
you can do it home and bring it in sperm
is so stable if you've ever done this
you just bring it in it's pretty in a
little bit bit a little bit of I think
I'm I'm I'm not going to feain that that
my friend did this and told me but you
know it's it's kind of outrageously easy
in the sense that you just bring it in
and they'll like take it out in the
lobby and be like is that your name and
they'll do like very different than the
egg collection procedure so here's
here's what I'll say about sperm and
what I wish more men knew slm men did if
you're going to get a vasectomy because
you are choosing that you don't want to
have kids and we see many men who do
this they say they don't want to have
kids they want to go get a vasectomy yet
later on in life you don't have a
crystal ball about life is dynamic and
things can change if you're going to get
a vasectomy Go free sperm first why are
so many men getting vasectomies I don't
have the answer to that I think I had
heard this yeah a lot of men are getting
vasectomies even I think to just take
control over not having a child out
there when they don't want to so maybe
this explains the drop in birth rates
I'm just I'm just kidding it's
multifactorial but so many people even
if you're in your family let's say you
have two kids and yall decided you're
going to get the vasectomy so that you
don't have any more
children things happen terrible things
happen Life Changes there might be a
circumstance where you potentially would
have another kid if something really bad
happened or you just changed your mind
freezing sperm is so easy and so much
easier then if you don't not all the
sectomy reversals work especially the
longer that it's been reversed the lower
the likelihood that it's actually going
to work and very often if it does you
don't get sperm in sufficient levels for
timed intercourse and you're seeing me
in the office
and and freezing sperm is cheap I mean
it's relatively cheap it's like $400
right so it's it's much much cheaper
Allin than the entire egg freezing
process so to answer the original
question when you go through egg
freezing most people do fantastic and
we'll just use egg freezing and IVF
interchangeably here because what you as
a person is going through to harvest
your eggs or to take them out of your
body is exactly the same right the
distinction between egg freezing and IVF
is all about what happens on the lab end
of it after they've come out of your
body so if we have this group of eggs
that comes out of the Vault your body
doesn't want to allow them all to grow
even if it's a low number right that's
the check in Balance to not have so many
kids so we need to override that process
and what we tend to do with this is to
use a combination of hormonal
medications and very often I describe it
to patients as suppressing your body and
then stimulating it so if I can
temporarily stop the production of FSH
and you have a group of eggs come out of
the Vault and we can imagine that FSH is
their food and there is no food because
you're taking the birth control pill for
3 weeks these eggs are going to
synchronize be very small be very hungry
for lack of a better word their FS
receptors are going to open all up it's
like a nest of baby birds that are all
now starving instead of the hungry bird
gets the worm so now we go with this
suppression period for a few weeks we
can come in and give gatot tropen which
is FSH and LH FSH is now synthetically
made in a lab it's very easy it's a
synthetic compound that mimics the
structure of the brain FSH we actually
can't synthetically make LH very
interesting we don't have a way to make
it yet and so we use the purified urine
of menopausal women because when you're
in menopause your FSH and LH levels are
naturally so high because they're trying
to get that egg to make some estrogen so
um here are some the we've covered male
hormone Health before um and there's
been a discussion of HCG human chonic
genotropin and which is essentially
mimics LH in in the receptor it does yes
right so is um pregal at uh human chonic
gonadotropin is it purified from
postmenopausal women's urine or is ITN
it's synthetic HCG is synthetic and so
what why can't I'm talking about it's
called minpure minpure is a combination
of FSH and LH the reason why we give HCG
to men to try to stimulate the
spermatogenesis process which of course
if we could just give LH we' give LH
it's the same reason why we give HCG for
a trigger if we going to go through
fertility treatments and we're trying to
mimic that LH surge which naturally
would cause ovulation we actually are
giving HCG because it does mimic LH when
it comes to the receptor action of it
but when it comes to really especially
in getting follicular development and
the relationship between LH and FSH
meaning LH is really providing some of
the hormone substrate that we need to be
able to make estrogen and so you really
need some LH in a lot of people
depending on your protocol or if you're
older and you're naturally making less
the example or the offshoot would be
like the PCOS patient who has some
naturally High LH sometimes they don't
actually need LH in their protocol but
so who are these post menaa women that
are supplying their Ur they're paid yeah
I S imagine them on some Island some
place yeah yeah go go to the menopause
getting paid to urine it and it's called
menure like it's purified menopausal
urine right wild most people don't know
that they know now now they know and so
we use FSH and LH we'll just say in lack
of better terms those are the two
primary compounds that we're giving over
the course of on average a 12-day period
to get the follicles to grow grow and
the eggs to mature so you can measure
egg maturity by blood levels of
estradiol and by transvaginal ultrasound
so when you're going through egg
freezing or IVF you're taking these
hormone shots of FSH and LH and they are
getting those follicles to start to grow
the eggs are starting to mature we're
monitoring them along the way trying to
determine the time period where we think
most of the eggs will be in the mature
range these eggs have gotten to mature
you then are going to take a trigger
shot which allows that final stage of
meiosis so those chromosomes can
separate right we think about the egg we
remember that normal female genetics
46xx and I always think about in the egg
that these chromosomes are lined up your
eggs are Frozen inside your body when
you're born your eggs are in metaphase
of meiosis so that's when metaphase
chromosomes meet in the middle and
they're held apart by these meiotic
spindles and this is why are so stink
and fragile because they're held like
this and those myotic spindles just
absorb the wear and tear of your life
but when you use that trigger shot that
LH surge naturally or that HCG in a
cycle that's when you're going to get
that final separation into half the eggs
you know half those chromosomes into the
egg so for people listening think about
um like a zipper and you're pulling a
part of a of a zipper that then you now
have the the chromosomes just one one
you now have haveed the chromosomes
because why because in successful
fertilization the other chromosomes are
going to come from sperm the sperm and
that's why this process has more error
the older you are and the longer your
chromosomes have been sitting there
because those spindles are going to
break down and we're going to have that
increase in annup Ploy like we already
said purely because of this impact can I
ask a question about that specifically I
think now would be the right time to ask
which is that my understanding is that a
lot of the Dynamics of pulling AP part
of this zipper like thing these
chromosomes and then um is related to
mitochondrial DNA um because there a lot
of mechanics we're literally talking
about an egg splitting itself you know
in half Mitri is its Powerhouse yeah the
mitochondrial and so mitochondrial
health is a big topic these days um and
so we will be sure to touch on nutrition
supplementation and prescription drugs
that impact mitochondrial Health but
I've heard of a new procedure um called
three parent um IVF where they're taking
basically the DNA from the intended mom
that DNA from intended dad um and then
putting it into a a surrogate like a
donor egg that is where the DNA has been
sucked out and then you know because it
has Health healthier younger uh
mitochondrial DNA so you're essentially
um let's say you've got a a couple in
their like let's say late 30s early 40s
and they're not getting successful
embryos or implantations or whatever
things aren't working they'll take the
DNA from Mom and Dad and they'll and
they'll they'll merge it with a third
parent um encapsulation that there are
clinics that do this I know that um a
lot of this was actually been done in
Eastern Europe until until recently um
Mexico offers there are places in Mexico
that do this uh in England it's been
used to um solve uh mitochondrial
dysfunction um but in the US this is
still not legal is that right yes so the
purpose of what you're talking about
essentially when we think about
utilizing um a donor MIT or donor egg
the point of that technology existed to
help cure mitochondrial diseases which
are 100% fatal and so you would have
this subset of people who would because
if you're the mom you always pass on
your mitochondria to all of The
Offspring so if there's disease inherent
in your mitochondria everybody's going
to get it and these are very severe
diseases so the idea of this was first
to say hey can we overcome this
mitochondria disease and give people the
opportunity which it has done that right
now so it works when done properly when
done properly especially for that
purpose now that purpose is distinct
because those people aren't infertile
right there's something else going on
within their mitochondrial disease
utilizing that technology to overcome
age related changes in the eggs has not
been successful yet are we hopeful that
it can will people charge you money for
it in certain places yes but you're
you're hitting on a really important
topic is that the political environment
of embryo research in the United States
makes it extremely hard for us to be the
pioneers of new technology in this space
and that is because a lot of views about
an embryo or when does Life Begin that
happens here in the US that results in
limiting the availability and the
possibility of doing research in a
meaningful way on human embryos right
because it would require the destruction
of a lot of of and it would also and you
know I looked into this a little bit as
a from an academic perspective um to be
clear um it would also require that um
that the abortions be performed
differently because suction abortions
destroy embryos in ways that extraction
abortions don't so there's a very
controversial topic I mean it's um it's
something that maybe we'll return to in
an episode about stem cells in the
future yeah it's fascinating because
especially if you look at IVF whole
separate issue is that there's millions
of embryos that people are no longer
using because they have had success they
had extra embryos in the bank they got
divorce a variety of reasons and a lot
of people would like to donate their
embryos to science feel like hey I don't
want to have this embryo implanted I
don't want to carry this child but po
potentially could something good or
could help Advance the field but that's
not really a tangible option when people
do that what is actually happening is
their embryos are being utilized to
train embryologists which is valid right
to teach them how to thaw and freeze and
biopsy and do different things so it's
still useful but it's not in a
meaningful way like we'd really love to
be able to utilize to advance the
science especially for these embryos
that have been created yet people no
longer need them for family growth so
what happens to all the embryos that
people don't use oh it's fantastic
question right now they sit in storage
this is well this is a new problem okay
IVF is only 40ish years old embryo
freezing alone right the first IVF we
haven't even gone through the whole
process but the first IVF baby there's
no FSH LH to stimulate more of the eggs
outside the Vault to grow so they
followed the single follicle and they
didn't have the procedure which we do
now which is a minimally invasive
procedure procedure to extract eggs we
go vaginally with a needle attached to
the ultrasound and we enter into each
follicle and we drain it the very first
IVF you followed one follicle and you
went in abdominally with a surgery to
get put that needle into the follicle
and drain it out and give that just one
egg a chance and then of course there
was no embryo freezing originally so the
field is still rather young to
understand some of this and as
technology rapidly
improves we see things like better
success rates with freezing and Tha
embryos better process of getting more
embryos to grow but now we have a lot of
embryos in storage that may or may not
be used I personally tell people you
should keep your embryos you should pay
the storage fee until no matter what the
worst thing on planet Earth happens to
you you're down having children because
sadly I live in a spectrum with my field
where I see a lot of sadness and people
who maybe have lost a child something
else has happened and they have maybe a
sibling who they feel like they really
want to give this sibling child the
chance to be a sibling again and often
you're much older when you're
experiencing this and if you had had
embryos Frozen that you could have used
but you got rid of them you're going to
be really upset if you find yourself in
that circumstance so I always say you
should save them until you know that you
are not going to need them and then what
do you do with them most people just
discard them some people will donate
them to Labs which is called for
research but mostly it's for
embryologist training to get better at
doing better which is also important
okay um but embryo donation is a new
thing so being able to just like we have
people who donate sperm and donate eggs
embryo donation is the next evolution of
an opportunity to allow more people to
become parents it's a little bit of the
Wild West people finding people in
Facebook groups and connecting it's this
whole other Dynamic when it comes
to what we call third party reproduction
or you know what do you do with known
donors and things like that but it's a
very interesting concept so this problem
is
emerging as the technology is getting
better I I'm realizing now um
remembering rather that when I was in
college and graduate school you would
see these um ads in the student paper
fre for egg donors and sperm donors um
sperm regenerate throughout the lifespan
so that's a kind of less controversial
issue but this is now not allowed most
places to advertise for for egg donors
on college campuses that's my
understanding um the egg donors were
often paid whatever whatever they were
paid I'm not going to say it was
reasonable amounts or not because I
don't I don't recall what they were paid
and everyone's circumstances are
different but the argument that most
people use against this is oh these
these people are giving up eggs that
they could otherwise use but we now know
that's not true so um do you have any
knowledge as to like what was the um the
rationale for for kind of limiting the
recruitment of egg donors um anyway I'm
not arguing for or against I just I it's
no longer supported based on what you've
said by the um by the argument that
they're losing eggs they would otherwise
be able to some of about proper consent
uh especially at an age where the
financial incentive can be very
persuasive without understanding that
makes sense not that it harms your
fertility later but that you're going to
have genetic children out there and you
might potentially and we are seeing this
now we don't know if you individually
will have infertility for a variety of
reasons because you're not trying to
have a family until much later but the
same concern doesn't seem to exist for
men who are donating sperm like I mean
it should there's this whole donor
conceived Community where people are
really talking about putting new
restrictions on will you sperm donation
for example there are sperm donors who
have hundreds of children hundreds right
there are these sibling pods because
it's been so unlimited and sperm banks
are a business that work to make money
and they make money by selling more
sperm but that's not healthy one for a
population you need genetic diversity
but also it's not healthy necessarily
for one person to have all these half
siblings and to just not know when
you're going to run into somebody who
could potentially be your sibling is it
this guy at the bar that you like do you
have to worry about that if you're donor
conceived so we're starting to see sperm
banks finally start to reel back and put
limitations on how many families total
children's tough right because one
family might have a child and you want
them to be able to have sibling children
but at least for how many families that
that donor can contribute to and we're
seeing sperm donors deal with the fact
that now there's no Anonymous donation
we can act like Anonymous donation
exists meaning it is not identified at
the time that somebody's utilizing the
sperm but with you know direct to
Consumer Testing for genetics like 23
and me and ancestry people are being
connected with their sperm donors with
their egg donors with their sibling pods
and we have to believe that technology
is only going to improve over time
so what people do for money especially
when they're young I think without
understanding the potential
ramifications and I don't want to act
like sperm donation or egg donation are
bad they give people the opportunity to
become parents that otherwise might not
be able to and that is a lovely and a
beautiful gift but you need to
understand what that might mean and how
that might impact your own potential
children later too to know know that
they have genetic half siblin out there
egg donation people do get compensated
much better than sperm donation there
are certain characteristics that are
hard to find that get compensated even
more so and certain you know ethnicities
Doctorate Degrees and things like that
where somebody can really pay for their
education by donating their
eggs it's a it's a dilemma because what
you'd love to say is like freeze some
eggs for you too if you're going to do
that you're at the perfect age to freeze
your own eggs and there's been
strategies to try to mitigate this and I
don't want to get off too much on a
tangent but it's a really fine line that
you walk with what people understand so
there is a company and I won't name them
but they are promoting that young women
donate their eggs and they will freeze
half of them for you and half of them
will go and become donor eggs now
interesting business model but I could
see the potential ethical concerns so I
think ethically this sounds good because
you get to freeze some eggs but I think
more people will donate eggs than
otherwise would have for some of the
reasons we previously stated and I also
think you would get more money by simply
donating your eggs and then turning
around and paying for a round of
freezing your own eggs you would get
paid more and you'd have more eggs
because one of the issues is do do you
now falsely believe that you enough eggs
in the bank because you did this split
but you don't really have enough because
we already walked through the math at 20
eggs doesn't really result in such a
high probability of having a multi-child
family so you know there's a lot of
ethical debate in gam an embryo donation
it definitely is the wild west and
there's a Uncharted
Territory even an embryo donation
there's places who are very unethical
about it who will
only allow people to have embryos if
they are heterosexual been married for 3
years make a certain income submit to a
home study yet they let the people have
no say over the embryos that are
transferred be it how many what stage
what quality and they are taking
people's money and putting terrible
embryos inside of them and really
wasting their resources which could have
been used in another way yeah the
dangers of
prophetie right and Tech I mean Tech
entering spaces is amazing but also
technology starts to advance before
studies right Tech is going to become
has more Finance backing than we see
scientific studies get I feel like one
of the major questions out there is
whether or not IVF babies let's just
call them that have a higher incidence
of things like um Spectrum conditions uh
or other developmental trajectories
let's call them and I'm not trying to be
politically correct here but you know I
think nowadays that the word um disorder
has to be like really carefully examined
when considering any uh neurologic um
and psychiatric um situation um you know
we've had discussions about this on this
podcast before but but a lot of people
are wondering just to be to be direct a
lot of people are wondering do more IVF
babies have autism um than non-ivf
babies is this a good question and it's
changed over time in a couple different
ways and I think this is important to
understand so if we just think about the
hormonal environment with natural
conception and you know you have a peak
estrogen let's say of 200 something you
have progesterone being made the
placenta is implanting and what is the
main difference with IVF babies and a
lot of it has been tied back to the
uterine environment especially in what
we call Fresh embryo transfers which is
really not a common practice anymore
so in a fresh Embryo transfer I'm going
to take the eggs out of your body
fertilize them in the lab and grow out
embryos and then I'm going to put the
best embryo back in your body 5 days
later at the natural time of
implantation and if we rewind the clock
that's how IVF was done right when you
couldn't freeze embryos very well and
they didn't survive and You' put lots of
embryos inside because they wouldn't
survive and that's the early days of IVF
when you saw a lot of multiples a lot of
high order multiples and of course
multiples have their own distinct issues
that put them at higher risk for
developmental disorders and issues with
development and birth RIS in general
right they're they're common to be fair
they're commonly referred to as as
disorders I just think um around autism
in particular there is there's a camp a
growing camp out there that um want want
it referred to differently we we've
covered this uh anytime this comes up I
bring up both just to highlight the fact
that yes we are aware and sensitive to
that emerging issue right now on
unfortunately for sake of conversation
there's no new nomenclature so we could
easily get um caught down in in the in
the attempt to try and like you know um
smooth over everything with everybody
and and it and as a consequence confuse
everybody so I think we'll go for
clarity forward with the understanding
that the nomenclature is changing can't
even say alcoholism anymore because it's
alcohol use disorder and I don't have a
problem with that but a lot of people
wonder if those are two different things
it's just confusing and we want to
simplify science for people exactly so
feel free so when we first doing IVF
we're putting embryos back in an
extremely unnatural environment if you
have 20 eggs growing and each egg makes
200grams of estrogen suddenly now you
have these extremely high super
physiologic estrogen levels higher
progesterone levels because there's more
Corpus ludum and this environment is not
the normal for how the placenta would
invade into that maternal blood circulat
and a lot of these issues that are
commonly associated became so because of
placental issues so a lot of things like
growth restriction small for gestational
age pre-term birth which further puts
you at risk for other developmental
disorders were associated with these
fresh transfers the field has changed we
do a lot of frozen embryo transfers and
a lot of it for this reason we see huge
Improvement in neonatal outcomes when
you bleed off that high hormonal uterine
environment and then regrow the lining
of the uterus and a hormonal level
that's more natural and then transfer
the embryo and we see completely
different fetal outcomes so that's
fantastic as far as looking at the
change over the field but of course if
you take all IVF babies over all time
it's a little murky because you have
modern practice and old practice we also
know that
infertility people if you get diagnosed
with infertility so you're under age 35
and you try to get pregnant with regular
periods for one year and have not had
success U or you're 35 and older and
you've tried for 6 months and you've not
had success you meet the medical
definition for
infertility when that
happens you now statistically regardless
if you get pregnant naturally in the
next month or you do IVF you have a 1%
higher chance of birth effects and you
have a slightly higher chance of
Developmental disorders so is it more
populationbased versus procedure based
and there's probably something to that
to underlying a lot of potentially what
goes in or what can cause infertility
when it comes to you know quality of
eggs or sperm or uterine environment or
things that we're still learning about
when it comes to autism specifically the
number one strongest Association we have
is Advanced paternal age so when you
look at the people and the male sperm
comes from an ejaculation after age 50
that one does have the highest
significance associated with autism and
also with some other very interesting
autismal dominant disorders so we don't
want to take Advanced paternal age
likely although it does get so much less
attention than what we call Advanced
maternal age or being over age 35 in a
woman and that is purely because of the
differences in the sperm and the Egg
environment and how their quality is
impactful thank you for that answer I
think um it's really important for
people to hear that uh because you know
the the lore out there is that IVF
higher incidents of of autism and IVF
babies but it sounds like a good
percentage of those um could be because
of age- related factors um as well as
technology related factors that um and
that the technology is getting better
all the time um if I understood
correctly uh we didn't complete the
discussion of of IVF and I want to do
that talk about ixie and a few other
things I know that's that's definitely
your wheelhouse before we do that can we
inject a little sub conversation um
around this because uh I neglected to
bring this up earlier and I know there's
a lot of curiosity about this and then
we'll and then we'll uh finish off IVF
can we do that sort of a pause in the
IVF so the eggs are out they're frozen
sperm's out it's frozen or maybe they're
going to put um live sperm on a
non-frozen excuse me uh sperm directly
onto those unfrozen eggs we'll pause
there intermission for those um
potential
embryos um and talk about something that
you've been um very open about which is
um and a lot of people are not frankly
in your profession so I really
appreciate this which is nutrition and
supplementation to optimize the the
health of uh egg quality and and not
just for people who want to get pregnant
but for but for people who believe that
fertility is a proxy for overall health
so I mean are there things that people
should eat and not eat um things that
people should supplement and not
supplement in order to um optimize their
fertility I mean this is definitely an
interest of mine right all my fellowship
research Cycles around fundability and
natural fertility and I think we really
do a disservice by how medicine really
is categorized by organ systems because
we act like things in one place don't
impact the other as if right but it's
you have a body and your body and
especially your hormones change and
fluctuate and they're meant to they are
meant to be a dynamic system but the
world and the environment of which you
are injecting your body to has proven
changes on both hormonal function and
also when it comes to egg and sperm
quality and so if you are somebody who
just wants to live your healthiest life
and have your most regular periods and
have your hormones as well balanced as
they can be for a lack of a better word
we'll just say that that means that
they're functioning normally then paying
attention to the things that you do are
really important and so I know this is a
big one for you sleep is probably the
number one thing that people don't do
that does impact their reproductive
hormone system and therefore can impact
egg and sperm quality because sleep is
when you have cellular repair and when
you can drop your inflammation levels we
know that inflammation is just toxic to
eggs and sperm it is the inflammatory
environment is not ideal for conception
and then for a female you have to deal
with the fact that you have your egg
quality but you also have how
inflammation or what you're exposed to
impacts your an environment so you have
a twofold situation here so none of this
should be shocking news when it comes to
nutrition but it is not talked about
enough you're right decreasing
inflammation by the foods that we put in
our body is consistently shown with an
improvement in fundability an
improvement in ovulation and an
improvement in success with IVF and a
decrease in miscarriage right huge
Studies have looked at these now the Vic
caveat is that nutrition studies are
super hard because people who consume
flax for example tend to have other good
health behaviors that sometimes make it
hard to identify what flax did versus
their General Health versus somebody who
eats fast food every day so nutrition
studies tend to be observational and
Fertility Studies are really hard too
because what inpoint are you using is it
getting pregnant is it live birth are
you looking at IVF are you looking at
natural fertility and we have a lot of
different overlap that makes both of
these a little bit difficult and so
they're all cohort-based or
populationbased studies where you
analyze how people perform when it comes
to fertility treatments or getting
pregnant naturally based on their
exposures to certain
things diets highend fruits and
vegetables are good for you right fiber
antioxidants fruit is not bad fruit got
this really bad reputation really I love
fruit I love fruit too but people think
that it has sugar and that it's bad for
you it has fructose but but no it's not
that type of sugar is not bad for you if
we can just agree on the fact that fruit
has a lot of nutritional benefit
especially when it comes to vitamins and
antioxidants that can be extremely
beneficial in decreasing
inflammation grains so whole grains
especially that your body you know
provide a lot of great fiber so of
course if you have Celiac or you're
gluten intolerant you're a different
category but there was so much focus on
keto and people eliminating brains as a
food group overall and even though that
might be utilized in a dietary strategy
to lose weight and losing weight can
improve
fertility likely because of inflammation
being the primary driver because we know
that even in studies where I take donor
eggs and I transfer that embryo into
somebody who's overweight they have
lower odds of success than if they were
a normal BMI so we can't act like that
causation is just on egg quality from
obesity right there's also some
inflammation some inflammatory changes
that impact the body's ability or desire
to allow an embryo to implant
so fruits veggies whole grains are all
good interestingly you know dairy dairy
tends to be okay in most studies but
what we do see is that if you're going
to have dairy have whole have the real
thing the processed Dairy the skim milk
that actually increases your fertility
and likely because the processing to
make it still look like milk when you
take out the fat is adding in things
that are unnatural potentially impacting
your fertility I don't drink milk
anymore but when I was a teenager I
drank half and half I'm not recommending
anyone do that remember I was a skinny
teenager I was you were trying to bul up
well no I just could afford to I wasn't
trying at that age I wasn't trying to at
all but um it was just delicious um but
so cheeses um whole uh full fat milk
yogurt half and half yogurt okay yeah
but don't don't choose the skim one
choose the actual one that comes with
some of the milk fat fat is not bad for
you there's also this right hopefully
we're getting away from it but there's
been such a lowfat craze or this real
attention that fat is so bad but fat
comes in so many important
forms avocados and oils and nuts Dairy
meat fat and cholesterol are the
backbone for all hormones right so you
need that in order for your body to make
the estrogen and progesterone that it
needs to allow this whole process to
happen and so there's this idea that
those are bad for you that's just really
not so healthy fats whole grains fruits
veggies and what about proteins and
meats because I think within those
categories you know I I'm a big fan of
sustainably you know like raised Meats
if if if possible some people choose not
to eat meat but fish eggs um love it all
okay so let's just go through the meats
and the myth and the fact so we'll do
tofu so there's this big issue that like
tofu has soy and that too much soy can
be bad because soy can be a
phytoestrogen tofu does not negatively
impact fertility even in Men In fact it
can improve it because it does have some
antioxidant like properties lots of iron
when it comes to fish fish are fantastic
sources of healthy fats and omega-3
fatty acids which are very crucial in
the reproductive process we do worry
about if you're pregnant having too much
fish and overexposure to Mercury and how
that can impact fetal brain development
so the general recommendation is three
servings per week that doesn't let me
guess a serving is like four to six
ounces as opposed to like a real human
that eats you know a real human yeah
thats yeah that eats you know you know
six to eight ounces of fish right and I
think it's important to say even though
people will tell you that when you're
trying to get pregnant with the idea of
we don't know when you're going to be
pregnant if you're going through things
like egg freezing or IVF and you know
when you're going to be pregnant I
wouldn't feel like you have to restrict
yourself on the consumption of seafood
during those time periods when you know
you're not pregnant yet because really
the concern is about that mercury and
what it could potentially do to a fetal
brain and raw seafood correct no sushi
no Sashimi well when you're pregnant
correct and that's mostly because of the
risk of infectious disease that can
cause you know severe brain development
and other issues what do they do in
Japan I don't know I don't live there
they probably laugh at this they
probably do laugh at us probably do
laugh at us someone who's who's um uh
been pregnant in Japan yeah reach out
tell us yeah or conceived in Japan tell
us don't tell us the story of the
conception like but tell us tell us oh
did you have
Sashimi overall meat is a really broad
category and studies study it
differently like is it all meat are you
distinguishing out red meat and chicken
are you putting it all together I mean
obviously I think we can all come to the
agreement that processed meats are not
good for for a variety of different
reasons in addition to being
carcinogenic those toxins do negatively
impact fertility now so deli meat no
bueno so yeah but and specifically those
things like the bacon and the pro like
the things that are really highly proy
hot dogs sorry the Fourth of July hot
dog picnic but those things really do
not provide nutritional advantages and
only harm especially then when we have
red meat for the most part red meat when
isolated individually in most
circumstances in moderation tends to be
fine I usually tell my patients I want
them to eat a plant forward diet but
that doesn't mean no meat but I say look
at your meat servings I don't want it
red meat every single day because there
was a study looking at IVF and looking
at embryos and the more servings a lot
of nutritional studies base things on
cortile so who eats the lowest and the
second most and the third most the
topmost and people who ate in that top
cortile of red meat had lower
progression of embryos through the
culture so less embryos that developed
less normal embryos and lower success
rates and do we know anything about the
how that meat was arriving are we
talking like like hogy sandwiches or are
we talking about like grass-fed steaks
right the studies are not wonderful but
that doesn't mean that they don't hold
Merit and helping us guide counseling
but no that one was how many servings of
red meat do you eat in a week right so
we don't really know does the really
ethically sourced the grass-fed you know
this environment which we feel like is
much less toxic than potentially let's
say like a cattle Factory where the cows
are injected with all sorts of things is
there a difference and how those impact
your
reproduction probably right if this
cow's getting injected with a lot of
hormones why are we thinking that it's
not impacting the meat that you're then
ingesting into your body no I think our
audience will certainly um subscribe to
that uh idea I think most of them will I
mean the notion that like the pollutants
you breathe in the air somehow are not
the the air that you breathe into your
lungs is is just like
completely and the idea people feel that
way and they hold strongly to this idea
that it can't be this thing that I love
that is causing this problem right the
denial of the association between what
we put in and on our body and how it
impacts our body's function is really
strong in some people and I think it's
really
just lack of education and awareness
because the medical community for so
long did not address these factors right
your doctor never talked to to you about
nutrition and so it just became this
idea that it must not matter otherwise
your doctor would talk to you about it I
think sugar is the last thing I just
didn't mention but added sugar and
artificial sugars are bad for you
artificial sugars artifici icial sugars
too so including Stevia s of plant-based
art low calorie sweeteners Stevia itself
hasn't been studied as much as the other
ones things like sweet and low all of
those MH but what we do know is that
they interfere they cause inflammation
inside the body and then they also cause
can cause a stress reaction and they can
cause higher rates of miscarriage when
you intake more sugar and artificial
sugar so that's a lot to wrap your head
around and I say this same thing to
every
patient one cake one this one hot dog I
mean those things individually are not
going to make a difference right it's
the choices that you make every single
day that are going to set you up to be
your Healthy self or not and so you
should make choices in line with how you
want to treat yourself you want to be in
your best health you want your hormones
functioning the best and if that added
helps you get pregnant when you want to
helps you have a better chance of
success with IVF oh my gosh what a
fantastic benefit but that doesn't mean
you can't enjoy some of these bad things
here and there as long as you've set
yourself up on the dayto day where
you're giving your body lots of
nutritious food that it needs to make
hormones similarly being you know very
underweight and calorie restricting we
all know is really terrible for your
reproductive system and can cause the
brain to totally shut down ovulation
because it senses that you can't have a
pregnancy people miss carry excuse me
for um by virtue of being underweight
does the body like like I learned um
some years ago I think this is still
true that one of the signals for the
onset of puberty in females is that
leptin um hormone is secreted from body
fat yeah um that then signals to the
brain to the hypothalamus like okay it's
you know there's enough reserves to
create uh environmental it's a signal
about environmental um yeah there's
enough extra fat to have a baby yeah and
there's presumably enough food around uh
to sustain that baby right are
miscarriages and lack of body fat
correlated on both ends of the spectrum
yes right so lack of body fat and being
overweight we see decrease in getting
pregnant per month and we see increase
in losing pregnancies so certainly there
is a healthy medium where your body has
what it needs and that makes sense
because if you have I like to even say
hypothalamic dysfunction so maybe your
brain's not to toally shut off where
it's sending out no hormones and you're
not ovulating because you're not getting
pregnant in that circumstance but
certainly ovulation disorders are on a
spectrum where you go from a perfectly
synchronized cycle to one that prolongs
it you know gets shorter together then
prolongs and then you have nothing
there's this spectrum of dysfunction
which is representing your hormones not
being necessarily perfect and that can
have impacts on the placenta trying to
grow into that uterus I mean the
placenta is fascinating right right an
entire talk just on the placenta but it
has it does this incredible job where
your body has to not reject it yet allow
it to eat away at the side of your
uterus and grow into your blood vessels
but that requires a very specific
hormonal environment for it to be done
and to be done right I think in the same
breath of all this what you're also
asking is yeah okay so that's eating
healthy none of that's really new news
for most people a lot of those things I
just said well I think so but I do want
to thank you because I think um rarely
if ever do we hear somebody so a
physician be really direct about like
Hey listen some red meat yes not
excessive amounts of red meat ideally
from uh sustainable sources whole fat
milk products grains fruits vegetables I
mean those kind of um straight what like
to you seem like straightforward
directives are are actually pretty rare
in in the landscape of of Public Health
discussion because um more often than
not people talk about nutrition and
these kind of Elimination Diet type
things like you know eliminate all the
grains or eliminate all the meat or um
you know eliminate all the milk milk
fats when in reality I think people
forget that like most people out there
are omnivores and they can make better
choices about not deli meat you know
less bacon if any bacon right have some
veggies with your lunch right like you
can make better choices on the
day-to-day I think that that is a great
point I think there's a place for
supplements I think the big disclaimer
that everybody's going to say with
supplements is that they are not
regulated like the way medications are
right and I will say supplements and
herbs are different things right a
supplement but many companies are adding
herbs to their supplements and that can
get into really murky territory
especially when it comes to how some of
these herbs do have estrogen and
progestin like properties and can impact
reproduction and hormones and perhaps
even androgenic properties too so we
can't act like everything's created
equal so I always tell people if I
recommend you take a supplement or your
doctor does your due diligence is to
look at what is also included and make
sure it doesn't have these extra added
things that they're unaware of because
sometimes they can have negative impact
at one stage of your life or another
depending on where you are certainly you
know a prenatal vitamin which has folic
acid we all know that folic acid is
really important to prevent neural tube
defects but it's also important in cell
division and how the ovary is growing
follicles and growing eggs so should
people women but also men be taking a
vitamin with folic acid even when
they're not trying to
conceive there's no harm in having it
but very often pregnancies occur when
you're not trying to conceive and that
is a store that needs to be built up
three months ahead of time so we really
need you to be taking that ahead of
getting pregnant so not just let's get
pregnant right now I'm going to start
this prenatal vitamin so I recommend
anybody who's in their reproductive
years take a prenatal vitamin we also
know that many many people are vitamin D
deficient and vitamin D does impact
reproduction and so I usually say a
thousand international units of vitamin
D is not going to be harmful in anybody
it's going to be helpful for most people
some people definitely need higher
levels so we screen everybody with a
vitamin D to see who needs to have extra
but you know a blanket statement that
extra vitamin D is going to be helpful
omega-3 fatty acids also extremely
important in one being anti-inflam at
but to brain development of a fetus so
most prenatals now actually do have
those omega-3 fatty acids in them but if
they don't I recommend a patient take
those just a brief um question insertion
there the um there's a laboratory up at
the University of California Santa
Barbara that's published some really
interesting data showing that you know a
essentially brain weight which is just
but one indirect measure of brain health
but brain weight in uh at Birth seems to
be correlated at least in some positive
way with the amount of essential fatty
acids that Mom consumed during pregnancy
does that sound does that yeah I mean
that does hold and
there's like there's mice studies about
that mice are smarter when they have
diets you know with omega-3 fatty acids
when they are in utero right so the
exposure on the time period is really
important and Omega-3s have a lot of
health benefits when it comes to their
antioxidant properties especially in
like an endometriosis diseases that are
very highly
inflammatory they can be very beneficial
we're definitely going to talk about
your work about after baby has arrived
and impact of essential fatty acids but
what would you say is the dosage cut off
um on this podcast before I've sort of
thrown out numbers like one one to two
grams per day of the EPA form of
essential fatty acids and we could have
a whole discussion about omega3 Omega 6
ratios but do you you think there's a
upper limit is is it truly that you know
let's say up to four grams per day of
EPA a um is would that be advantageous
is it better than one gram I tell people
a gram a gram okay that's in alignment
with pretty much what we've talked about
before so that's what I recommend you
know when I give my handout to my
patients and they're trying to get
pregnant it's going to have a prenatal a
thousand IUS of vitamin D gram of
Omega-3s and then CoQ10 so CoQ10 which
you know essentially in general is
trying to help the mitochondria that's
the whole idea here that it is helping
Provide support
across the body in a lot of different
ways right like kqen is used in a lot of
different areas of the body but when it
comes to reproduction when it comes to
meiosis and cell division and ovulation
and egg quality and even sperm quality
there's a place for CoQ10 showing
benefit without harm right and so no we
said earlier nothing's without any harm
or any risk of harm but very very little
so I usually recommend if you're trying
to get pregnant and you take cooku 10 a
dose of 200 milligram three times a day
so there kind of a higher dose than
sometimes people are on um often
prenatals now have just like 200 total
in it and so the the expensive
ingredients are usually the the uh the
lower
concentrations just enough so they can
put it on the label right includes Co
CoQ10 um does the form of CoQ10 matter
because you'll find them in gel capsules
you'll find also find them in um
powdered capsules I always say I mean
there might be for the individual person
I mean absorption of medication is
really depending a lot on gut health and
other factors but the number one issue
with supplementation is that people
don't stick to it so I always say
whichever one you're going to
consistently take is going to be the
better form great um a question about
ELC carnitine um and researching a
little bit for this episode and others I
you know oral lcarnitine has been
associated with some improvements in
forward motility and sperm maybe egg
quality um but we know that a very small
percentage of the oral ALC carnitine
that one ingests is actually um utilized
so some people actually purchase and use
injectable lartin which is kind of
painful because it's in an alcohol-based
suspension so not not not comfortable
it's got to be done intramuscularly but
my read of the data is kind of
impressive I wouldn't say super
impressive are you ever injecting um
patients or having them inject
themselves with El carnitine um this
would be both male female or male
patients or both um or using oral El
carnitine or do the data just not
impress you enough to to motivate that
we use a gram of ELC carnitine with a
gram of vitamin C for our male patients
who have any abnormal sperm parameter
and so that is kind of what we consider
the sperm enhancement protocol and so
and just that that with the multivitamin
so those two with the multivitamin and
CoQ10 so that's kind of like the male
protocol of course there's different
specifics for one individual person I
don't tend to recommend it for most
females that being said those who have
inetrior where inflammation is so high
that usually it's a different
environment where we recommend
lcarnitine an aetl cystine vitamin c and
e they kind of fall into a different
category because theyve a known
inflammatory disease but if we're just
talking about the person at whole who
maybe wants to take some supplements for
their reproductive Health that have very
little side effects and for the most
part can potentially be helpful it's
going to be you know CoQ10 El carnitine
vitamin C can be helpful especially for
the male for the female partner we're
going to be looking add that extra
vitamin D in addition to the prenatal
with folic acid and what about women
with PCOS I get so many questions about
PCOS inositol so um and there are we
talking myosl or the what is it the dyro
do I have that right you do have that
right myosl is the main driver of a nosl
and how it can be helpful if you most
Blends are going to have a combination
of both of them but a much higher ratio
of myo andosol to deyro and so myosl is
probably the one that really is doing
the work in PCOS what is it doing it is
definitely helping the body when it
comes to insulin and sugar helping the
body be more sensitive to insulin or
less resistant to it essentially helping
you respond to what you eat in a better
way and it also looks like it does
potentially decrease some of that
inflammation pathway in PCOS in PCOS
this insulin resistance correlates with
testosterone production from the ovary
meaning even metformin alone can
decrease testosterone levels based on
some of the change that it has in the
ovary take note men so many guys taking
metformin or berberine thinking oh this
is great I'm going to lower my blood
sugar mimic fasting and live longer and
and then these are also the same people
who are writing to me go how come when I
take metformin I either have headaches
because I'm you know essentially hypo
hypoglycemic but also their testosterone
levels are are are getting crushed not
in every case but it happens and I think
those are things people just don't think
about they read that a supplement might
be beneficial for this one thing that
doesn't apply to them and they start
taking it so also the evidence on
metform an extending life we had Peter
on here talk about this like the
evidence for that is is like oh so poor
it's just not really that convincing it
may change but then now all the
excitement is about Rapa M and so you
know uh extending your life while
plummeting your testosterone you know I
mean that's a actually that strategy has
been tried in the longevity Community
there's a was this whole castration idea
I don't this oh yeah this was like the
Heaven's Gate cult where they castrated
themselves did they longer well they
ended up committing mass suicide so so
um that you know they ended the
experiment early um you know um yeah so
in any event um going back to
supplements sorry I couldn't help myself
um supplements that um women can
potentially take just to in increase
their fertility even if they don't want
to get pregnant as just kind of creating
a milu of Health you talked about the
nutrition talked about CoQ10 maybe Al
carnitine vitamin C um the essential
fatty acids getting at least one gram of
EPA so that might require taking two
grams of of fish oil to get that the EPA
myosl so how much are you talking about
I've seen some pretty high dosages
thrown out there for myos 2,000
milligrams okay taken before sleep or
does it matter some one doesn't matter
that one doesn't matter thank you for
covering the topic of supplements and
supplementation um this is probably a
good
point to return back to those harvested
eggs so eggs are out um and there's a
collection of them frozzen um maybe just
maybe uh live SP they're always alive
sorry um fresh sperm they call Fresh the
fresh sperm they're not always live some
portion of the ejaculate is going to be
um dead sperm right some live some for
motile some non um for motile the
twitchers I read is the name that hate
those twitchers right um and so okay
they're going to wash the the sperm why
because yeah most of what people see as
ejaculate or know excuse me as ejaculate
is um is not actually the sperm right
okay so but sperm are washed they're in
one compartment um you get the eggs out
you you or your embryologist at your
clinic is then going to at some point
decide to combine them so is it kind of
is it a sperm race or are you um maybe
you could explain ixie and and why would
one want why would one up for ixie and
is are there any risks with ixie because
there you're really at some level this
is the only place where I kind of sit
back and okay is somebody you you know
St neural development like some level
you're saying hey that sperm looks good
whereas when you run a sperm race nature
is saying hey this sperm really did beat
all the other sperm so let's segue first
because I think this is nice because the
question I get asked all the time when
we talk about nutrition and supplements
and all of that is to now you're doing
IVF or you're freezing your egg
and what if what behaviors are good or
bad of course all of those same ones are
but about how long do you need to do
them and this is why if you live healthy
most of the days it doesn't really
matter because that's how you're living
but we already know the sperm cycle is
about 90 days and the eggs I like to say
even though they're in the vault they
become they start lining up getting
ready to exit the Vault and become more
susceptible to the things you're doing
in that 90-day window and we know that
to be true as well so they start to be
pre- ected for who's coming out the next
month they start to line up and so
making these changes as you start
thinking about getting pregnant doing
fertility treatments is still extremely
beneficial people will often say well I
haven't been doing that so why start now
it's not going to make a difference but
truly it can or I'll drink up until the
week until the day up I'll just I'll
just get it in people like I'm going to
have my two glasses of wine which
actually equates to about six glasses of
wine when you measure out by how much by
the volume right right up until the week
before getting pregnant or something
like that but no so so people always ask
what should I be doing is these healthy
behaviors and you should be doing them
you know this whole time when we do IVF
and I'm going to get all the things you
just asked but earlier you said well how
tolerable is it the truth is you're
taking shots these are subcutaneous
shots during the egg growth process so
so next to the belly button yeah next to
the belly button like how a diabetic
gives insulin a very small needle I mean
nobody loves shots but they're not a big
intramuscular shot it's not like a flu
shot or something like that listen I've
been to Austin the Texan mosquitoes
worse they hurt way worse than one of
these needles exactly so you're going to
use those medications for about 12 to 14
days you're going to have your follicles
grow you're going to feel that so you're
going to have pelvic pressure as your
estrogen Rises you're also going to
third space your fluid which means your
fluid your water component of your blood
is going to start to just eek out a
little bit and you're gonna get more
bloated you're gonna have more water
weight you're going to feel puffier and
that is very common just because of
getting the eggs to grow you're going to
mentally be fine because the female
brain loves high estrogen so you're
doing fine as and that's one of the main
concerns is how emotional will I be and
during this phase of the process people
do great when we take the eggs out of
the body it's about a 20 minute
procedure it is usually done under IV
sedation like propal and Fentanyl and we
are watching while we drain those
follicles and get test tubes full of the
eggs do some people often not use any um
say I hear the word Fentanyl and I'm
sure a lot of people are like wait
fentanyl crisis and I you know obviously
fentanyl is a drug that has its uses um
valid uses in the um medical community
um does anyone just kind of opt for you
know just I mean we have an
anesthesiologist who is really talking
to the patients I mean propile is the
base of it certainly there's some
patients who may want to avoid narcotic
usage and they use different strategies
I mean there was this huge right the
retrievals podcast came out from like
the New York Times doing a deep dive
into a fertility clinic Yale where a
nurse was siphoning off fenel for for
herself and replacing it with sailing
and giving patients saline these this
Clinic did not do anesthesia based
propofol so they were supposed to just
get fentel and have kind of a less pain
environment not a no pain environment
and not not just a few hundreds of women
reported extreme pain extreme pain
through the procedure really speaks
largely to pain not being taken
seriously when they went and found this
out who what happened to I can't help
but ask what happened to this uh
technician well I mean yeah they're
they're they're trying to find fentel
Behind Bars yeah I mean and but it's
huge as far as to like I mean I can't
imagine I can't imagine doing I do this
procedure like all the time right I've
done thousands and thousands in my
career and I can't imagine having people
be in pain during it so it's but it's
important to know that some clinics
don't use IV sedation or they don't use
propol they don't put you to sleep
understanding what your clinic is using
is really really important to set the
expectations or to know am I going to be
awake or am I going to be asleep can a
patient ask you know what specific drugs
are you going to give me to kill pain
for sure and I mean some clinics only do
one like I am not going to do a
retrieval under no sedation now some
clinics would allow that some clinics
that's all that they do but you that's a
huge piece of the puzzle that you need
to know if you're a patient are you
going to be feeling pain not feeling
pain what's it going to be like I'll say
most clinics use propol and put patients
to sleep and so you take a nice little
nap for 15 to 20 minutes the eggs are
retrieved from the follicles under
direct visualization they're in test
tubes you wake up and you're going to
feel
crampy and you'll get a period 10ish
days later but this is when you'll feel
your worse and this is just the one
thing I want to say about tolerability
of it can you get pregnant in that time
yeah yeah yeah and there's a a case
report of an egg donor who was donating
her eggs and she had sex with her
boyfriend and because not every egg is
always retrieved from the fices or some
small ones could ovulate too and she got
pregnant with quintuplets whoa okay so
you have to really tell people not to
have intercourse one from an infectious
standpoint because we really are poking
you know a pretty large gauge needle
through the vaginal mucosa into the
perinal cavity so we don't want to
introduce infection but also for
pregnancy in that time period And if you
got pregnant your risk of what we call
ovarian hypers stimulation syndrome or
ohss is very profound so what is
normally happening is after the
retrieval your estrogen and progesterone
are going to drop you're going to feel a
severe PMS for lack of a better word so
when you'll be more emotional you're
still pretty bloated until this all
heals if you get ohss
which is very uncommon in modern
practice but when you did fresh embryo
transfers or people who don't utilize
some of the modern protocols this means
that HCG continues to encourage all
those follicles to make estrogen and
progesterone and if you are pregnant
you're just going to have a constant yet
exponential increase in HCG and so this
is going to get worse and worse so we
really don't want people to get pregnant
in that time period so when during that
time period should they avoid sex so is
it in the few days before the extraction
so typically I usually say it's from
like day five of your stimulation okay
so usually the earliest egg retrievals
are kind of around cycle day N9 or 10 if
somebody goes fast until your next
period comes so that's usually about a
three week time period where we want you
to abstain from
intercourse so for the most part though
the more eggs you have the more you're
going to feel both both this hormonal
and physical shift than the fewer eggs
that you have so if you have a low egg
count and you need to do IVF or freeze
your eggs and you might do multiple
Cycles or rounds you're going to
tolerate it actually pretty fine because
you're not going to have these huge
shifts physically you're going to feel
fine and that's always a big concern
when you mentioned earlier about
different stimulation
types people have this idea that things
that are more natural are better right
just like this human thought that
natural is good and synthetic is bad
naturally you ovulate one egg a month
when we're trying to get eggs out of
your body the success is determined by
how many eggs I can get and how young
you are so it doesn't make sense in most
circumstances to do a minimal
stimulation protocol meaning
purposefully under stimulating Somebody
by saving the money and medication cost
in order to purposely get fewer eggs
because their odds of getting the
ultimate success of what they want is
going to be so much lower is there I
don't want you to be in the position of
I don't want to put you rather in the
position of kind of like having to
demonize your your colleagues in your
profession but I could see how there's a
pretty significant financial incentive
for people who are really desperate to
have children or who just simply might
want to have children down the road to
um they hear low stem is better we're
talking multiple low stem Cycles they
might be um even fraction of the cost of
a full stem cycle but then there many
many more low stem Cycles you got it you
can make a lot more money by doing
things that are not in the best interest
of the patient and I mean that's not
uncommon in my field which is very sad
but it does mean that because
reproduction and IVF are so foreign and
unknown so many people walk in blind not
knowing if what they're being told
really makes sense for their situation
there are a couple situations where
minimal stimulation makes sense if
you're only going to make three eggs
you're only going to make three eggs I
don't need all the drugs in the world to
tell your body to make three eggs cuz
there's only three and so that is a
scenario where minimal stimulation does
make sense and then there's the scenario
where there's something called invos
cell has your research exposed you to
this no invocell is a way to try to take
IVF into making it more financially
accessible for certain patient
populations mainly people who don't
ovulate like your very refractory PCOS
patient who doesn't respond to
medication or who have tubal Factor
infertility right so your fallopian
tubes are blocked because of chlamidia
or
endometriosis and we just have a problem
here that egg and sperm can't get
together because you're not ovulating or
your tubes are blocked an invocell it's
a
device that is plastic and you can fit
up to 10 eggs in it and there's a little
Middle Chamber where the sperm can go
and so you go through this IVF process
with the goal to only get 8 to 10 eggs
because that's what fits in the device
and then you put the sperm in the middle
of it and then you put it inside your
vagina and you hold it in place with a
diaphragm and the vagina is the right
temperature to incubate and so you
incubate your embryos in this little
invocell container inside your vagina
and then 5 days later you come in and we
take it out and we take the best embryo
and we transfer it and you can do a
fresh transfer because you didn't make
so many eggs so your hormones weren't so
high do people like this procedure
there's something that seems like yeah
like staying in proximity to the sperm
and egg like you're Tak you're taking it
home okay so I love this procedure in
some some circumstances and I see it
applied often in the wrong case and that
that can be frustrating right because
it's still not cheap even if it's
cheaper than IVF it is still not
inexpensive in any means and so patient
selection like most things in this field
are so important so let's just say if
you've had no like if sperm if the
sperm's the problem then it's probably
not smart to just presume that the sperm
and egg will be fine in there right like
that might be a case where you really do
need help with assisted fertilization or
if you have unexplained infertility if
we don't know why you haven't been able
to get pregnant because everything looks
good on paper what if fertilization is
the issue and these are circumstances
where you pull out an invos cell and
there's no embryos and you don't really
know where when wrong was it the
fertilization step was it the growth
step of the embryos and culture so you
do have less data notably I like data
you can't do genetic testing and this
isn't really a strategy that allows you
to freeze embryos for future family
growth that being said the young patient
who's got great egg quality who might
have really bad PCOS or tubal disease it
can certainly allow them the opportunity
for a child at a lower price point when
they still have many reproductive years
to finalize their family it also is a
lovely option for people who need donor
sperm to conceive because the success
rates with this are so much higher than
an IUI which is what a lot of people use
an intrauterine insemination or putting
the sperm in the uterus so now we're
able to improve this outcome so like our
same-sex couples or our single parents
by choice if it's a single woman who's
trying to become a parent then they need
to buy donor sperm and go through the
process anyway this often can improve
that efficacy through the process
pending their age and other factors
there was a study that was just really
neat there's a lesbian couple and one of
them the eggs came out of and the other
one incubated the embryos and then the
other one had the embryo transfers so
but it gave both Partners a way to feel
a little more involved in the process
which I just think is always a really
cool way when you have these different
options with reproduction seems also so
um that it's a more of a
three-dimensional environment like I
always imagine that the petri dish is
approach um is so two-dimensional
compared to the body and all these
things having done cell culture before
and you know cultured neurons and things
of that sort like there's all these
concerns about like the concentration of
CO2 in the thing or you know you know
God forbid if there's a a fluctuation in
you you have backup generators and
things but in the electrical flow to the
incubators that's disruptive whereas the
the natural environment of the body even
though it fluctuates in temperature it's
I mean this has evolved over you know
tens of thousands if not you know
hundreds of thousands of years to be the
process by which embryos are created so
there seem so here's where I sort of
default in my mind anyway uh to the kind
of like oh like it seems more natural
you're incubating in the more quote
unquote more natural environment but at
the same
breath wh why are you having infertility
if you're an infertility patient right
so if you need donor sperm you maybe
don't have infertility or if you have
tubal disease you have a very defined
reason and why we don't think that
there's this huge inflammatory issue in
your body or something unknown so again
I'll see it applied to people who really
are bad candidates for it based on their
age or based on their diagnosis and so
it's not always better but for the right
patient I mean I've had patients have
babies that way who otherwise may not be
able to so it can it can really open up
the doors so that's the most minimal of
the minimal stimulation right then we
have minimal stimulation because you
don't have many eggs so you don't really
need that but for the vast majority of
people who go through egg freezing or
IVF we are really trying to get as many
eggs as you potentially have everybody
has a different number but whatever you
have whatever that Antro follicle count
is for you is what we're trying to get
and that's what these combination of
medications is trying to do when the
eggs come into the lab if you have egg
freezing very important to know is
before we get into the iie discussion
the eggs are stripped of their outer
cells which is called the cumulus that's
what the sperm has to attach to in order
to fertilize in order to freeze the eggs
the cumula cells are stripped off the
eggs are frozen you have to do ixie so
if we're going to lead into this ixie
conversation if you're freezing your
eggs you're having ixie when you
fertilize them so I don't want somebody
to ever not know that if that is what
they are choosing and iie is you can
tell us yes iie stands for it's icsi or
intracytoplasmic sperm injection it is
taking a sperm that under the microscope
looks normal in shape and moves well and
you're pulling it up into a little
needle and you're essentially using a
little laser on the side of the egg or
the zon of palu of the egg and you're
injecting that one sperm into that egg
cytoplasm and you're picking that sperm
on the basis of shape motility you're
picking what you think is is the best
sperm in the batch obviously yeah you're
picking I mean there's going to be one
sperm per egg so there's m multiple
sperm that are chosen but you're picking
sperm that look like they have the
highest potential and my understanding
is that there's a range from very low to
potentially high but hopefully not high
of DNA fragmentation in pretty much
every cell of the body like the cell is
always repairing its DNA so when
visually selecting a sperm uh for for
ixie it's it's based on morphology shape
and motility right you can't see the DNA
damage inside the head of the sperm or
the DNA itself are we are we soon to
have a technology where you could
actually um like get a do that could
label DNA fragmentation and and select
um because I feel like so like when we
talk about embryology not to get too far
down in the weeds but um like the the
methods of selecting eggs and selecting
sperm I mean these are the same methods
that have been used in embryology for
like since the 1930s like oh this one
looks good that one looks good and the
skilled embryologist can can really
develop a a real talent at over time of
like knowing what correlated with
healthy pregnancy and and an offspring
but I do like technology you would think
that by now 2023 that someone would have
some diey that you could drop on the
sperm and go well like that one has a
lot of DNA fragmentation and that one
doesn't know right there should be
better ways to choose which sperm
there's definitely people are trying
things nothing has proven to be helpful
so far there's definitely some interest
in this because we're starting to get
more insight as we have become better at
embryo culture getting embryos to grow
doing genetic testing on embryos to
understand that that male genome kicks
in at day three and there's a upset of
people who have beautiful fertilization
and embryo growth days0 to three and
that's all on the egg and then as soon
as that male genome kicks in you have
this huge drop off in your embryo number
and even some of this is in the context
of normal sperm parameters right so
things aren't really normal though or
there's something underlying it and does
that mean that every embryo failure on
day three post fertilization is no of
course not but it definitely means that
none of the ones before that can be
blamed on the sperm and ones after that
there's definitely still maternal and
sperm contributions and we don't want to
create any um you know a couple uh
disputes around this um but it can be an
Insight when you're trying to look
through somebody's IVF cycle about
potentially modifiable factors right can
you improve sperm quality by some of
these lifestyle measures I mean the
debatable thing about a DNA sperm
fragmentation so what is that it is not
a normal semen analysis but it is like
that as far as it's a sperm sample that
is then sent off to be evaluated how
much fragmentation or abnormal DNA is in
the heads of those sperm the Studies
have shown that people who have abnormal
DNA sperm fragmentation should do ixie
okay that's like the point of the study
now ixie become very common place so
ixie choosing the sperm to put into the
egg originally didn't exist right so
what's the
alternative conventional fertilization
this is having your petri dish your eggs
are on it you squirt your sperm you
cover it up you put it in the incubator
she didn't mean you squirt your sperm
she me she meant the tech the
embryologist embryologist squirts the
sperm on top be clear just to be clear
and then pulls it out and the next day
sees by which eggs and sperm
fertilized well it's really devastating
to pull out the dish and have no
fertilization and it definitely is a
cause of infertility and it can be very
hard to know that because fertilization
is not challenged on a cellular level
until you challenge it so ixie used to
be an add-on cost it used to be a
separate thing because it was harder to
find embryologists who could do it it's
so standard that a lot of clinics do it
the majority of the time purely because
you often don't know all the variables
that are impacting fertilization and
you're trying to give somebody as many
opportunities as
possible ixie has in a lot of those
original IVF studies got some of the bad
reputation of being the problem with why
you might see that 1% rise of birth
effects and so ixie took the brunt from
a lot of that we really don't see that
when we're growing out and we're doing
freezing the embryos doing Frozen
transfers and I was I mean I do I in
almost every patient I'm not going to
say in everyone higher probability of
success probability success and when you
get to this point and so few people have
insurance coverage so they're spending
their money they're getting second
mortgages they're taking out loans if
there's one decision that you say well I
don't know you could have zero eggs
fertilized or I could have the
embryologist pick the best sperm and put
them inside the egg and we expect a 75%
chance of fertilization that makes sense
for the majority of people yeah that
that that makes sense to me I um because
I'm obsessed with data on you know do
blood work fairly regularly not not
obsessively but fair you know twice year
so um now I didn't always do that and I
actually did one of these um DNA
fragmentation tests that they're pretty
expensive you know they're in the they
are more than a Sean analysis yeah
they're they're in the you know low yeah
they're sort of $1,200 $1,500 or so at
least the one that I did it was very
informative like it was reliev to see
not abnormal levels of DNA fragmentation
but I will say that based on everything
you just said it seems like it might be
the lower cost option because you know
the alternative is to go through
repeated cycles of IVF and it's failing
and that's certainly much more expensive
it is and I mean I will say that there
is some current thought by my Urology
colleagues right so I am not a urologist
but definitely when I have a male who
you know needs a sperm extraction maybe
he's had a prior bomy maybe he's got
very low sperm counts and we're going
and we're doing a sperm extraction
procedure that potentially if you have a
patient who has an abnormal DNA sperm
fragmentation and even with ixie has
this drop off in embryo growth after day
three because the sperm are still being
made the same way right are they still
fragmented that potentially the
ejaculatory process could cause some of
that fragmentation in certain men and by
going in and doing a sperm extraction
and not subjecting those sperm to the
rigors of ejaculation for lack of a
better word could
potentially lessen the fragmentation and
improve outcomes and I have some
patients who we've gone down that road
and that has helped them clear to say
there's not a study that it's not the
point of DNA sperm frag is to try to
distinguish if potentially ixie could be
a helpful technology but a lot of
doctors are offering or doing ixie
because we want you to fertilize your
eggs when they grow out in culture as we
talked about ibf changing the metabolic
needs of the embryo you know change
throughout the process and so embryo
culture has become so much more
successful but even in those best case
scenarios we're looking at 50%
progression so you're going to have loss
through throughout that culture process
no matter what and you said 50%
progression so half of the fertilized
embryos that make it past day let's say
day seven then there's screen for
chromosomal abnormalities so then okay
then you've got um let's say two or
three of those maybe four depending on
how many eggs we harvested and your age
and then and and age yes thank you and
then and then you said of those that are
implanted into let's say a woman you're
45 or younger you're looking at about
anywhere from 30 to 65% um successful
implantation and pregnancy like healthy
baby it's usually 65% chance of Life
birth if it's a genetically tested
embryo that that that Aster is the if
and that's why you're going to see such
varying IVF success rates because if you
don't do genetic testing of embryos
let's use the 40-year-old who makes four
embryos and I send them off for genetic
testing I anticipate she has one normal
embryo if I do genetic testing which
takes it's called PGT pre-implantation
genetic testing I am testing for anupy
is the traditional testing meaning does
it have the right number of chromosomes
you can also importantly test for single
Gene disorders like cystic fibrosis or
huntingtons but if we're just doing PGT
for anupy I expect an age related
proportion of your eggs to be normal or
abnormal so at age 40 I expect 20 to 25%
normal so I can choose that one and put
it in you and have a 65% chance that you
have a baby I could not do it I still
have the same four that one is in there
but if I go and transfer them each
independently I'm now going to have
closer to a 20 to 30% chance of success
right so it is not that I'm changing the
embryo by testing it but I'm allowing
myself to have higher utility of success
higher efficiency putting somebody
through less failed transfers which is
extremely important and less
miscarriages because those also take
time and one of the most important
things is that you have the opportunity
to understand how many potential normal
embryos you have in batch Cycles so you
could could go and do another cycle
because I'm 40 I just met my person I
really want to have two kids because my
sibling is really important in my life
yet Naturally by the age I would be for
that second child it's going to be very
hard to conceive I can go through IVF
and batch some embryos so I could save
two or three for that second baby that
I'm not going to transfer for a few
years and that's called embryo Banking
and that is changing the ways that
people can potentially grow their family
at later ages but you don't know that
unless you know what's normal or not and
it also gives you the chance to go and
intervene right now because right now
especially if you're older I'm going to
have a higher chance of success than if
I am four transfers down the road and
maybe there was one miscarriage in there
too we're suddenly now eight months down
the road before I can go do another
cycle and get more eggs versus if I
found out that none of those were
genetically normal the average
40-year-old might have 0o to one if they
have average ovarian reserve per cycle
so they're going to need multiple Cycles
it's not that it's impossible but it's
just setting that road of expectation
for them but if I don't get any normal
embryos I can turn right around and go
get more so I am using what's left in
that ovarian Vault each month to try to
get to that opportunity of a pregnancy
for you in a much more efficient way by
utilizing genetic testing of these
embryos this is where we can put an
ellipse in and sort of like do dot dot
healthy baby right and um maybe in the
future uh if we're lucky he'll come back
and talk to us about um healthy
pregnancy um and uh healthy baby onward
um that would be a a fun and important
set of
discussions I would like to touch on the
I don't want to call it the issue but
the topic of menopause which I assume is
defined as the sensation of menes um but
there I'm guessing and I'm guessing it's
a constellation of things that happen
happen um and I have a very
straightforward question which is is
there an acceleration of the onset of
menopause are we seeing that nowadays um
are there good data on that um should
people try to delay menopause what are
some of the things that um you talk to
patients about in terms of their
considerations of ways to ease that
transition or maybe even offset that
transition with um hormone replacement
therapy or other other approaches these
are great questions and I do think this
is going to be a huge interest
in upcoming years as we have learned
more about the menopausal transition and
the health risks really associated with
being hypoestrogenic or having low
estrogen menopause if we Define it as
ovarian failure so your ovaries now have
no eggs or so few eggs that they are
refractory to the brain sending out FSH
so your brain is sending out all the FSH
and LH that it can your ovary is done
and not making any estrad or
progesterone anymore in this time period
what we know is one are we seeing a
populationbased increase in earlier
menopause there's not been a study to
say that observationally and clinically
I would say yes because I see so many
younger women having low ovarian reserve
or having premature ovarian failure or
premature ovarian insufficiency which is
the more politically correct way of
saying it but when we think about what
this is is there are modifiable factors
right if running out of eggs is a
variable and we already said certain
things like smoking cigarettes and
exposure to toxins and likely chronic
inflammation and untreated disease we
know that having diabetes those things
increase your risk of going into
menopause earlier so paying attention to
the lifestyle that you have when you're
not concerned about your fertility right
when you're in your younger years and
maybe you're not worried about getting
pregnant yet or you're not worried about
menopause
but those choices that you're making in
those time periods at least for women
your eggs are going to hold on to them
so they have an influence later
similarly trying to live a lower
inflammatory life and getting sleep and
avoiding toxins of which you can is some
of the best that you can do to try to
naturally prolong when you'll go through
menopause with a huge caveat that
everybody is truly born with a different
number and you do not control that you
don't and so you might have been born
with a lower number and you can't change
that trajectory and you might have
cancer and be exposed to chemotherapy
which also will deplete your ovarian
reserve but so do things like
endometriosis especially if it's not
being treated in any fashion so that's
where we think the birth control pill or
progestin exposure or surgery ways to go
and decrease the inflammation it's that
inflammation associated with IND
metriosis that's really causing these
women to have low ovarian reserve and go
into menopause early so not only is that
impacting you know fertility and how
many eggs you get and how long you have
to grow your family but when you go into
menopause earlier you have lower life
expectancy than people who go into
menopause later and that's why you even
said it earlier fertility is this
variable kind of reflecting longevity
and like Health overall so what we do
know about menopause is that having that
low estrogen whether that happens at the
average age of menopause at 51 52 or at
an earlier time period it's not good for
the brain you know higher risks of
dementia increased risks of osteoporosis
increased risk of heart disease and
stroke and essentially higher risks of
death and that's not even to talk about
the impact on your life what it can be
like to have hot flashes heat and cold
insensitivity to have profound vulvar
and vaginal atrophy to the point that
you no longer want to have inner core
and the changes that it can even have on
your gut and your immune system so we as
a community you know of doctors
especially OBGYNs really recommend
hormone replacement therapy in women who
are going through menopause and the key
here is to initiate it right at the
beginning that big Women's Health
Initiative study which came out forever
ago and showed all this harm with
hormone replacement therapy the big
issue there was that these people were
hypo estrogenic for 10 plus years in one
group and then started back on the
hormones and in that circumstance they'd
already been put into this higher risk
category and their body had adjusted to
not having the hormones and when
reexposed they had more Adverse Events
but if you are starting on estrogen
replacement and it it can be various but
honestly the estrogen that we try to
replace in this time period much more
mimics estradi we have estradiol pills
you can have vaginal inserts you can
have patches so it depends on what's
going to work for your life but it is
not the birth control pill most oftenly
and some people it might be that's what
they choose but we really are trying to
pick an estrogen that is estradi more
mimics that natural structure and you
can't have unopposed estrogen without
reaching the risk of endometrial cancer
and so that's why we need to have some
progestin so some people will choose a
daily progestin some will choose a
cyclic progestin and still periods some
will put in an IUD at this time period
and then take their daily EST estrogen
there's a lot of different options we're
trying to find the lowest dose of
hormones that relieves your symptoms to
provide you relief from some of these
lifestyle issues but also helps you not
just live longer right we're not just
trying to live longer we want to be
healthy longer we want to have a better
quality of life and certainly Women's
Health has for long stopped at this
menopausal period and then it's been
you're on your own kid and this is when
we're really starting to see that
intervening at that place
especially for women who go into ovarian
failure early so those people who have
low ovarian reserve who I diagnose I
tell all of them hey if you don't freeze
your eggs or I never see you again
you're going to go through menopause
early and when you do I want you to go
see somebody I don't want you to just
ignore it and suffer with these symptoms
which is something that does commonly
happen so just making sure that women
are empowered to know that these
symptoms are what happens it's what
happens naturally but by giving their
bodies more estrogen and not crazy high
doses but just these physiologic levels
can really improve both the quality and
the longevity of their life is it just
the presence of these symptoms that
signals the onset of of um of menopause
or is is there are there additional cues
like for instance if their cycle is
getting shorter or longer you certainly
will have cycle changes and we consider
that the per menopause period where
you're starting to really start seeing a
spacing out of your periods so they're
no longer coming at that perfect
ovulatory pattern when you get into the
low ovarian reserve but you're still
ovulating regularly they first shorten
as we said earlier but then when they
start lengthening or you start skipping
months that's a real big clue that that
things are not going in the right
direction and if you find out you have
very very low ovarian reserve or you're
approaching that per menopause period
you're going to start to have more
prolonged periods of low estrogen and
you'll
feel mentally cloudy fatigued more
headaches more hot flashes Lac of libido
those vulvar vaginal symptoms overall
more likelihood to have depressed mood
and that's a lot there's a lot well
Natalie Dr Crawford I want to extend a
huge thank you on behalf of myself I've
learned so much from you today uh about
fertility about Hormone Health for women
and you've also touched on a number of
important issues about Hormone Health
and fertility for men along the way this
has truly been a a master class in
fertility and hormones and and really
touched on topics that are so essential
to everybody even if people aren't
seeking to conceive or maybe think they
don't want to I mean there's so many uh
considerations that really extend back
to one's teens and if one is beyond
their teens like whatever age people are
essentially they need to think about
these issues and make important
decisions and you've really also
clarified a lot of the what I think are
quite destructive myths that that are
prominent out there about for instance
egg Harvest and what that does to one's
fertility so first of all thank you for
joining us today I know you're extremely
busy you run a clinic you have a you
manage a family as well a co-manage a
family I I believe but um you know this
is the sort of of knowledge that is so
challenging to find in one place and yet
you also have a number of really
spectacular avenues that you deliver
information Instagram podcasts books and
things of that sort we will refer
everyone to to those links um I've
learned so much from you over the years
really um in following your content and
today you've just uh like far exceeded
all already high expectations so um
thank you ever so much thank you for
having me and just thank you for giving
a space to talk about women's health and
fertility and Reproductive Medicine it
means a lot to me and it means a lot to
the people who really are trying to do
their best every day so we appreciate it
we appreciate you and with some luck
we'll convince you to come back and talk
and bit more on some of the topics that
that we move through quickly thank you
thank you thank you for joining me for
today's discussion about female hormones
and fertility with Dr Natalie Crawford
you can find links to her clinical
practice as well as to her social media
Handles in the show note captions please
also check out the link to her excellent
podcast entitled as a woman if you're
learning from and or enjoying this
podcast please subscribe to our YouTube
channel that's a terrific zeroc cost way
to support us in addition please
subscribe to the podcast on both Spotify
and apple and on both Spotify and apple
you can leave us up to a five-star
review please also check out the
sponsors mentioned at the beginning and
throughout today's episode that's the
best way to support this podcast if you
have questions for me or comments about
the podcast or guess that you'd like me
to consider hosting on the hubman Lab
podcast please put those in the comment
section on YouTube I do read all the
comments not during today's episode but
on many previous episodes of The hubman
Lab podcast we discuss supplements while
supplements aren't necessary for
everybody many people will derive
tremendous benefit from them for things
like enhancing sleep hormone support and
improving Focus if you'd like to learn
more about the supplements discussed on
the huberman Lab podcast you can go to
live momentus spelled o us so Liv
mous.com
huberman if you're not already following
me on social media it's hubman lab on
all social media platforms so that's
Instagram Twitter now called X threads
Facebook LinkedIn and on all those
places I discuss science and science
related tools some of which overlaps
with the content of the huberman Lab
podcast but much of which is distinct
from the content on the huberman Lab
podcast so again it's huberman lab on
all social media platforms if you
haven't already subscribe to our monthly
neural network newsletter the neural
network newsletter is a completely zero
cost newsletter that gives you podcast
summaries as well as toolkits in the
form of brief PDFs we've had toolkits
related to optimizing sleep to
regulating dopamine deliberate cold
exposure Fitness mental health learning
and neuroplasticity and much more again
it's completely zero cost to sign up you
simply go to hubman lab.com go over to
the menu tab scroll down to newsletter
and Supply your email I should emphasize
that we do not share your email with
anybody thank you once again for joining
me for today's discussion with Dr
Natalie Crawford and last but certainly
not least thank you for your interest in
science